[Music]
I'm the one
yeah the purpose of this podcast to
figure out what movie I mean it's a big
name that produce Alexander the grid I
just think somebody else should do the
Alexander move okay I would not mind
seeing anyways folks you just kind of
walked into this podcast we're talking
about Alexander and uh we do have an
Alexander type of a guy for the
progressive side today in the house Kyle
kulinski in the house thank you uh very
happy to have you uh everybody's been
saying Pat why don't you get Kyle on you
got to get Kyle on you guys got to talk
about different issues I said let's get
them on and I'm glad you made it out man
my pleasure I'm very happy to be here in
Miami yeah and it's good that you're
turning it into vacation oh yeah no I
wasn't gonna escape the cold of the
Northeast for like a day or two I wanted
to really soak it in yeah well I try to
go the other way Ron we we just got back
from Aspen yesterday and I got to tell
you guys what happened real quick so on
the way back from Aspen we're getting to
the plane
well no flights are leaving okay great
pilot you know my guy Joe says hey you
got to go uh 90 minutes out I got 13
people with me and you got to go to a
city called rifle I've never heard of
rifle so we go to Rifle to this airport
and uh uh we're at the airport we get to
the plane plane's not working oh okay so
we stayed last night at not the Holiday
Inn at the Comfort Inn the rifle in oh
man
we stayed at Rifle Colorado yesterday at
the Comfort Inn so what we did is this
was appropriate for you it's not
appropriate I couldn't hear kids out to
watch Avatar because I wanted to see
their reaction for the last 30 minutes
of the movie which was found I don't
know if you've seen Avatar 2. I've seen
the original not the second one I think
it's really cool to watch if you got
kids there's a message to the last 45
minutes that's about how kids become the
leaders of the family it's a very
emotional moment where I'm watching my
kids to see how they react to it and the
Dylan at the end I'm like so tell me
what you think is that I got the chills
like tell me wise because it's kind of
weird it's a great it's a great movie
for family we watch Avatar we got on the
plane we came out here uh I won I'm glad
you were able to change your schedule
because I know yesterday was a day for
us to do this podcast yeah our guys
contacted you go ahead I really I relate
to your struggles at the airport because
we and we're one of the lucky ones but
we had a two-hour delay on the tarmac
got it yeah when we took off we took off
from DC and oh man it was crazy the
captain would chime in every 30 minutes
or so and say yeah uh we just spoke to
air traffic control and uh they're gonna
touch base again with us in about 45
minutes and we'll see where we're insane
I know and there's little kids on there
playing and stuff and you're looking at
them and Nancy and then I'm getting
Nancy and it's like we're not even there
yet yeah it's like you know two hours
and 45 minutes it's crazy because when
we went to the movies you know kids were
making noise screaming and people behind
me are so pissed off and 15 years ago
I'm the guy that's like how are we
responsible why would you bring kids to
the movies people are trying to watch a
movie right like I don't have the moral
Authority anymore I don't because it's
me apologizing listen I'm so sorry hey
guys come on keep it down anyways but
regarding flights again 66 of Southwest
Airlines flights canceled at what point
do you recognize the weather like we've
all seen this movie before blizzard
coming in flights are going to be
delayed as you're on your way to the
airport right right or like at what
point you just call an audible and just
say honey
you know we're not gonna go see Grandma
this week or we're not gonna go see like
we'll deal with this next week I just
feel like you're driving head first Into
the Storm with these flights and you're
like [ __ ] it we're going for it see but
with Southwest it just wasn't the
weather there are other things too there
were other things very very Antiquated
system in terms of how they make their
schedule I was just reading about this
the other day and uh I mean yeah they're
just getting away with with crimes here
you know they need to crack down on them
and let them know you guys can't do this
there's got to be some penalty for this
because a lot of I mean I'm sure you
guys have read this too there are
situations where they book flights and
there is no pilot at all and then people
show up and they're like oh we don't
even have a plan for you that is very
important as well that's right they
overbook flights as well I mean this
stuff can't be allowed Rob what do you
got here more than 90 of Wednesday's U.S
flight cancellations were so holy moly
so it's not like it is all across the
board it was singular to Southwest right
according to flight tracking website
fight aware Southwest canceled more than
2500 flights the next highest Skywest
with 70 this is not a good look good
look for Southwest Southwest typically
gets it right right uh Southwest warned
that it would continue canceling flights
until it could get operations back on
track the company CEO said that this has
been the biggest disruption he's seen in
his career debutment Administration is
investigating okay we're not going to do
anything they're not going to do it I
guarantee but who's who's the head of
Transportation right now isn't that
people to judge yeah you don't think
he'll do anything about it you think
he's more executive Platinum with
American Airlines than the Southwest
well what he's doing is he's just
abiding time before he runs for
president again that's all he's doing
did you like him when he ran will you
saying I like Pete yeah absolutely not
so you you were not a fan of his at all
well he was a hero for a lot of people
though oh no tell me why though tell me
why well I mean look the problem with
with Pete is that he's a young face on a
representative of the Old Guard in the
Democratic party so he represents the
Hillary Clinton Wing the Joe Biden wing
and obviously somebody like me I'm more
from The Bernie Sanders wing of the
party so we look at him and we see
Politics as Usual we see nothing
changing we see the status quo
but what part what part do you not like
about the Hillary Clinton about the Joe
Biden Wing what part do you not like so
a number of things first by the way do
you put Obama in that camp as well Obama
yes I would say he's like 75 in that
camp I mean I could list some things
that he did that I like but mostly he's
in that camp uh I mean look their
Economic Policy policy is what I would
call neoliberal corporatism which is
again a continuation of the status quo
um foreign policy wise he's hawkish
which again Falls right in line with
Hillary Clinton she brought us Libya she
helped get us the Iraq War Joe Biden of
course helped get us the Iraq War as
well so when I look at him I just see no
change
I see a continuation of the status quo
to you by the way what was most
frustrating to me you know I like a good
fight right I mean I don't know about
you but I like a good fight like I like
seeing yesterday Luca 60 points 21
rebounds tennis's first player ever to
do it I don't know if you follow
basketball insane statistic to do
something like that and the guy's
interview said did you know you scored
60 points did I I scored 60. I'm tired I
mean just something that you've never
seen before I like a good fight it was
overtime I like a you know uh Joe Bro
against you know Tom Brady or even the
World Cup sick a good fight yeah that
was it was so annoying when the
announcement came about well you know
Elizabeth Warren Pete bootage uh uh
everybody else uh Bernie Sanders is
dropping out and they're all supporting
Joe Biden I wanted to see you have no
clue how bad I wanted to see Trump
against
oh that would have been insane I
actually think they have some things
that they agree on which would have been
interesting uh because I don't think
they both like the swamp I think both of
them are against the swamp and it would
also this is the second time they did it
Hillary did that and now Biden did it
which is quite frustrating to see that
happening when you see that two times
and that's your guy how do you feel
about it how do I feel about Bernie
getting stabbed yeah yeah no I mean look
it just it tells you that there are very
powerful forces behind the scenes at the
top of the democratic party that would
pull out all the stops in order to
prevent somebody who would break the
mold from taking power Bernie I think is
more in the mold of an FDR an FDR very
famously took on powerful interests and
what happened is in the 1990s Bill
Clinton came in and he was this new deal
Democrat is what they call or excuse me
not New Deal Democrat new democrat which
just means uh they had the DLC
Democratic Leadership Council they
decided instead of us taking Union money
teacher money we're also going to start
taking the same corporate money that the
Republicans are taking and so they
decided hey look I'm not on the left I'm
not on the right I'm kind of in the
middle and I'm above The Fray and I'm an
enlightened Centrist and what they did
is made us the Democratic party was no
longer a party of working people and
Bernie Sanders was trying to bring it
back to a party of the working people
and they would not let that happen
because they have all the money Bernie
Sanders you know he uh famously his
campaign was built on small dollar
donations and that can get you a long
way but when there's more money on the
other side and they're way more
organized and to your point that is the
organization that you just discussed
when you had you know what was it mayor
Pete better O'Rourke he had all these
people drop out on the exact same day
right before a big election and endorse
Joe Biden Joe was doing great it's not
like Joe was he wasn't he got destroyed
in Iowa he got destroyed in New
Hampshire and look if they didn't do
that Bernie Sanders would have won
because so that was the biggest fear the
biggest fear was what if Bernie takes
over and some of these ideas some of
these guys get some momentum correct
yeah and also I think Bernie if Bernie
was President I think he would have put
Obama's record to shame and so Obama
also has a vested interest in in what
way in what ways Obama has a vested
interest in not allowing Bernie Sanders
to become president because if Bernie
gets in there Bernie does let's say
Universal Health Care well that puts
Obamacare to shame because Obamacare is
this you know terrible half measure
which keeps the for-profit health
insurance companies in control and so
yeah I mean he he was screwed he was
Carl for the audience said there's a no
you real quick but I mean obviously you
you've done very well you have a YouTube
channel that's done well I think got a
billion views on YouTube you were with
Jank from 13 to 21 uh uh and then you
got your own thing that you're doing and
you've been around you know we just you
just told us who your engagement is is
it public can we yeah yeah everybody
knows crystal ball Crystal Ball from the
hill she's a rock star uh you know her
her show everybody was following her in
her apartment soccer yeah they were
doing a great job but uh so your that's
that's your background that's what you
believe in so if you were to kind of say
well these are the issues that I support
this is who I am what would those things
be yeah I mean it's very simple I would
just describe it as social democracy
okay so anybody can go to the Wikipedia
page for social social democracy and
read through it and that's basically
what my beliefs are so
um I believe in I believe in meritocracy
I might be surprised to hear that right
but I want the floor to be a reasonable
floor so I want people to have the
basics met and then from that yeah then
you achieve the most that you can so in
other words we're running 100 yard dash
yep I want everybody starting at the
zero yard line I don't want somebody at
the negative 40-yard line and then Mitt
Romney's son at the 85-yard line I want
to have a fair race I want to real
meritocracy so that means I want
everybody to have health care I want
everybody to have education I want
everybody to have the option potentially
of going to say trade school I want a
living wage for people so if they work a
full-time job they make enough money to
survive it's very basic stuff that I'm
talking about here I'm talking about
what I think the best countries in the
world at this point have already
achieved if you look at the Scandinavian
countries a lot of those countries uh
they they provide the basics for people
but then they also rank high and I think
you guys will appreciate this economic
freedom so a lot of these countries
score higher on like free market
principles than than our country does so
they cut all the red tape that you can
cut when it comes to business but they
also have the basics met for everybody
that's all I want I just want everybody
to you know get out what you put in
because certainly in the system we have
right now I think people feel like
they're getting a raw deal because they
are what do you think was common and
Adam I know you wanted to ask a question
so what do you think what commonalities
did you see between Trump and Bernie
like when you looked at the two what did
you say Okay obviously they don't agree
here they don't agree here they don't
but there is a lot of similarity here
what were some similarities yeah from
the two so that's a great question I
would say the similarities are an
affectation and posture so
um Trump came in in 2016 as an
anti-establishment Firebrand on the
right and I would say that a lot of his
rhetoric back then was very populist he
would he said in a 60 Minutes interview
yeah I'm gonna give everybody Healthcare
and they're like who's gonna pay for he
goes yeah the government's gonna pay for
it this is not something you'd hear Mitt
Romney or any other Republican say
um he also said hey I'm uh I'm
self-financing my campaign now the
details of that are not exactly correct
but still the posture was there very
famously in a debate he pointed at Jeb
Bush and everybody else on stage and
said you hear those people people
clapping the audience that's his donors
I don't have any donors in the audience
and this is something
yeah it was sick when he called out the
Iraq War to Jeb Bush's face in the
middle of a republican debate in a
military State I think it was North
Carolina and the audience clapped and it
was at that moment I think it was
actually Ben shapir who made this point
it was 100 correct he said on Twitter oh
this thing's over and this was early in
the race if you can get a military crowd
in North Carolina full of Republicans
against the Iraq War it's over and so I
think that the anti-establishment uh
Firebrand is what Trump brought to the
table and Bernie brought the same thing
on the left so I think the 2016
iteration of trump was populist right
and Bernie I think has always been kind
of populist left
um and they tapped into a real anger now
of course I think their Solutions are
very different and I don't agree with
Trump's solution I think he governed
more or less as kind of a standard
establishment Republican in many ways
but in terms of how he presented to the
country it was very clear that uh he was
taking this populist right
anti-establishment lane
this term populace always kind of
bewilders me it's like populism so I
kind of want to break down what it
actually means to be popular is you're
basically saying Trump was the populist
right in many fashions for sure Biden
populace left by definition what
populist just you're popular you're
saying things that the majority of
people want to hear but obviously Bernie
what he stands for is wildly different
than what Trump stands for so I guess my
question is how can they both be
populous what's the overlap right there
I'm sure a lot of people who supported
Trump would have actually voted for
Bernie because they kind of want to just
burn down the establishment break down
kind of what you think populism is today
well I would say it's just hatred of the
establishment and you saw that among
Trump voters you saw that among Bernie
voters the literal definition would be
something more along the lines of you
know doing the will of the people which
is true but I think that the connecting
tissue is that like anger at the system
whereas you look at somebody like
Hillary Clinton it was like support of
the system prop up the system explain
why I think the system is good you look
at somebody like Joe Biden same thing
you look at somebody like Mitt Romney on
the writer you know the other Jeb Bush
these people are hey we got a good thing
going on here the institutions are kind
of working so let's not fiddle with it
too much right that's their argument
whereas the trumps and the Bernies are
like this [ __ ] thing is broken and
that's why you guys are angry and so I'm
gonna help you change that so regarding
the system you know this thing's broken
this thing's broken I think we've seen
over the last couple years since Cove
had like the overreach of the
quote-unquote system and Trump famously
made the swamp so famous right but one
could argue maybe the system is kind of
what got us here these World alliances
trade agreements NATO you know you can
kind of argue the pros and cons of this
but for America the system hasn't been
all bad has it I mean it's you don't
want to tear everything down tear down
democracy everything we've worked for
because there's some bad things going on
no doubt there's something we can
improve so this whole like anti-system
thing yeah what's the validity with that
so there's a there's a vibrant debate
that's always been going on on the left
and it's reform versus Revolution and
the real hardcore types will tell you no
I believe in Revolution I'm an opponent
of Revolution literal Revolution for the
simple reason that you don't know what
the [ __ ] going to come after that and
you don't know how violent it's going to
be there could be dead bodies in the
streets is that something we really want
so what I believe in is basically the
strongest kind of Reform possible you
know I believe in kind of a a page one
rewrite of how we do it to try to get it
right and make it better so I hope that
answers your question so so let me let
me ask this sure so sell me the dream on
your ideas I'm a 22 year old okay
um I just got out of college I'm not
even that I'm in college I'm taking an
economics class and to have a speaker
one hour coming in and you're selling me
on the idea of socialism okay to say
okay I mean social social democracy okay
I mean it's different it's very
different yeah I'd like to know the
difference between the two but some need
a dream on hey uh Patrick you're 22
years old I'm a regular guy you know my
parents divorced I don't have a lot of
money my dad's a cashier at a 99 cent
store I came from Iran I lived at a
refugee camp I'm a regular guy there's
nothing about me that I'm coming with
family money
any of this stuff something to drink hey
Patrick you ought to one day dot dot dot
some eat that what does that look like
well I mean I think you should do
whatever it is that you want to do and I
think you should be able to have a shot
to do that fairly so in other words I
don't think you should go bankrupt if
you get medical bills I don't think you
should you know have student loan debt
that's so extensive that you can't ever
pay it back and by the way you also
can't file for bankruptcy on it because
that's the way that they wrote the laws
um I don't think people should be loaded
up to the brim with credit card debt
credit card debt is at a record high
right now I just read a stat the other
day 63 of Americans are living paycheck
to paycheck so really uh to sell you on
the dream I would honestly just point at
some of the Scandinavian countries and
say look they haven't eliminated
capitalism what they've done is they've
harnessed the good parts of capitalism
and mix it in with the good parts of
socialism so that they have you know an
intelligent hybrid where somebody who's
22 years old just getting out of college
can have a chance to do whatever they
want and make it so okay so and I I
rebottle because let's just say my uh
there's a classmate sitting there and
his dad's an executive at IBM hypothetic
and he's doing 600 000 a year and he
lives in a nice Community he says so
Kyle you know if my dad's told me if if
if these Scandinavian countries are so
great how come you're not moving there
and why is it that 40 million immigrants
choose to come to America and why don't
they choose to go to some of these
countries what do you tell that 22 year
old smart Ally well why I'm not going
there is because it's [ __ ] cold I'm
in Miami and I'm enjoying being in Miami
right now
um so if it was warm you would go is
what you're saying uh no because I love
my country I love America whenever I
criticize America it's coming from a
place of like I want to try to improve
it and make it better I don't think
everything about this country is bad or
wrong but I think that there are things
we can do to improve it and you know
there's a very famous quote from one of
the founding fathers dissent is the
highest form of patriotism in the same
way that if you know God forbid you know
we saw one of our kids but hide a
dumpsters smoking crack behind an Arby's
we be like you know what we're gonna try
to get them some help we're gonna try to
get you in rehab we're going to work on
this we're going to fix this it's that
same mindset that you apply to the
country it's you know when you look at
some of the things going on in this
country you say this can't continue I
mean we have 45 000 Americans that die
every year because they don't have
access to basic health care that's
something we can fix and it's and you
know there's a lot of uh work put into
convincing people that it's just a law
of Nature and there's nothing we can do
about it no there's a lot we can do
about it okay so let's stay on that
let's hang on I want to stand on this so
I want to go to the 22 year old and
selling the dream to this kid so going
back to it you know uh I don't know who
we had here on the podcast but uh
somebody recommends a restaurant to you
how do you and I judge a restaurant at
noon hey you know what I've never been
to Rifle before let's go there to eat
for lunch how do you and I judge a great
restaurant we've had a food taste how
the atmosphere is and then okay so the
atmosphere meaning what if if the place
is packed at noon and there's a hundred
people there and 20 people waiting to
get inside they're doing something right
okay if you and I go to a restaurant at
night and you're like there's a
restaurant in L.A rafi's place I go
there all the time if you go out there
on Mother's Day it's a three-hour wait
okay every day it's busy it doesn't
matter when you go out right if anybody
says anything bad about the restaurant
like to say well you know my my thing is
I want to make this restaurant better
because I think this restaurant can do
if they put the chairs this way and it's
not fair the fact that the employees on
the bus boys and I'm like yeah dude but
but it's a good restaurant but it's
always it's not it's not a good
restaurant because you and I have an
opinion that's a good restaurant it's a
good restaurant because it's always
flipping packed right so if America was
and I know this is a random analogy I'm
using but if America was a restaurant
America is so packed and it's got a
waiting list that if it's so bad with
the existing ideas that it has why do so
many people still want to come here and
not anywhere else well there's a very
simple answer to that question which is
if you look at the places that a lot of
these people are fleeing they've been
absolutely obliterated they've been
destroyed so a lot of these countries
have been ravaged by the drug war
whether it's you know I think in
Honduras I read a fact a couple years
ago in Honduras there's more violence
than there was in Iraq at the peak of
the Iraq War so it's a pretty crazy
place I'm gonna try to flee that I don't
know about you I'm trying to flee that
I'm going to try to take care of my kids
um you know Mexico similar situation you
have these these drug cartels
effectively uh with help from our policy
we've made these Narco States you know
south of us yeah and so you have these
you know gangster states that are run by
drug cartels because what we've done is
we've of course we did the War on Drugs
we made it illegal what happens when you
make it illegal is it gets pushed under
ground to the black market that's how
you make the drug cartels more powerful
the same the same thing happened here
with prohibition when it came to uh the
mafia we made the mafia way more
powerful because we decided to make
alcohol illegal that's when they got
their most uh power and wealth and so a
similar thing happened with the drug war
what I would do is number one stop
intervening in those countries
militarily and that's you know a long
conversation we could have about the
history of the US intervening in that
area and number two let's end the drug
war so in other words just kind of take
our our boot off the neck of a lot of
these countries and make it so that
people want to stay there because
honestly I really believe this I think a
lot of the people who are coming here if
they felt like their home country was
safe and clean and okay then they
wouldn't want to come here I think in in
many cases it's a desperation Type move
but it's not just Honduras or Mexico
it's it's like okay you're uh half
Italian and you're half polish I wanna
is it polish or uh yeah so my my mom's
mom is from Italy basically and on my
dad's side it's more of a my last name
kalinski is a Polish last name but it's
I think it's a little more uh
you take your uh Italian right you take
Jews you take anything else you take if
America is so bad that some people sell
it as being so bad why do people keep
coming here what is what is so like okay
when we were in Iran we had options
people were going in to Spain so we're
going to Australia some were going to
this only because they couldn't make it
to America but everybody's number one on
the list was to come to America you know
what I'm saying it wasn't like they
wanted to go anywhere else again going
back that that is my biggest argument
where if America is so bad if capitalism
is so bad and abusive why do so many
people who are actually leaving an
abusive environment are willing to come
to a place that offers capitalism where
a person who has not got the last name
of Mitt Romney his last name is BET
David my parents haven't given me a
penny last time I got an allowance I was
14 years old I'm not on allowance I
don't even know what allow to be honest
I'm not even being sarcastic I don't
know what an allowance is right and so I
come up here I'm like dude I don't give
a [ __ ] if you give me allowance I'm just
happy to be here and I'm gonna bring my
middle eastern work ethic and I'm
banking on something's good going to
happen to me I don't have the money to
go to school I don't have the grace to
go to school maybe I'm going to go in
the military get my act together be away
from some of these guys that are doing
drugs because all my a lot of my friends
were you know ecstasy you know pot they
were selling they were done like I'm
just got to get away from them so I go
into the military
and then I come out I'm like okay I'm
gonna learn how to I was a bodybuilder
I'm going to learn how to sell this is
my way out so again for me it goes back
to the same thing if if America if
Socialism or social democracy is so
amazing why don't people go to those
countries first before they come here
well so I would say number one there
actually there is a refugee crisis in a
lot of those countries there are people
kind of pouring into those countries but
number two I think we're talking a
little bit past each other because I
wouldn't say America's Best of course I
went I'm here I love this country right
the the question is I think it's just
the Wrong conversation to happen I'm not
a capitalism guy you're not well social
democracy harnesses the best aspects of
capitalism so so there is an element so
maybe maybe unpack the difference
so that you know there's socialism
there's Democratic socialism and there's
social democracy social democracy is a
hybrid of capitalism and socialism where
basically you you take the best aspects
of capitalism the best aspects of
socialism and you have this this mixed
system which you know in theory would
yield the best results and I just the
reason why I believe in that is because
I think there's a tremendous amount of
empirical evidence to those ends so like
for example they do this study every
couple years this Commonwealth fund
study where they look into the Health
Care Systems of basically you know a lot
of the developed countries 11 of the
developed countries and when they do
that we always rank the U.S ranks 11th
out of 11. so we're doing worst on that
front so
um now when it comes to the issue of
capitalism look I mean I could I can
make the argument for you here when you
look at for example the cars that came
out of the Soviet Union
they were abysmal they were you know
they were made by one government agency
there was no uh competition so you
didn't get a better product at a lower
price and that's that's what I'm trying
to avoid which is why I believe in
something like social democracy because
you can still have uh particularly when
it comes to consumer goods I think it's
good to have competition I think it's
good to try to get you know the best
price with the the best product and and
compete in fact I believe in uh and I'm
curious if you would agree with this uh
I think we really need to start doing
antitrust action again I think we should
do anti-monopoly stuff again because
when a business becomes a monopoly what
do you get higher prices worse product
and so you need to break them up just
like Teddy Roosevelt did to get it to
the point where you have more
competition you can harness the best
aspects of capitalism so when you talk
about that so I believe in that while at
the same time I also believe in taking
care of the basics so in other words
um they have like sectoral bargaining in
a lot of the Scandinavian countries that
means you set wages the union negotiates
with management and you set wages kind
of across an entire industry I think
that's a good idea because it helps
working people out more I believe in
like I said universal healthcare
Universal education or trade school you
could you should have your choice and I
think they do that in Germany they give
you an option you want to go to trade
school or you want to go to college I
just hate this notion that in this
country some people come out of college
and they're 80 000 in debt and they're
like well what the [ __ ] do I do now and
I can't even pay this back and then they
got to go take a job where they're way
overqualified to even take that job I
think that's [ __ ] up I just think
there shouldn't be such a thing as
medical debt or or school debt uh and I
don't think these ideas are all that
radical I think most people would agree
with this even people who would consider
themselves capitalists so let's go
through the school debt let's go through
the school debt so who who caused that
like meaning how did we get here because
40 years ago College wasn't that
expensive you know if you look at the
numbers of 40 years ago versus today I
think inflation CPI is 220 percent in
the last 40 years since 1970 or 1980s I
think it's 1970. and then uh cost of
college education has gone up 1200
percent CPI 220 inflation 1200 percent
how do we get to a point where college
has become a business it's no longer
like what it once was started for yeah
well College was free or nearly free uh
in California and then Ronald Reagan
came in and took that away so it really
is a matter of priorities
um I don't I think this is something
that honestly should be fully
nationalized I think we should have a
fully nationalized education system
trade school system
um I think this is one of those areas
where we've kind of experimented with
the free market and the results have
been disastrous in the same way that I
think for-profit health insurance
companies are basically just a legalized
Mafia That's in between you and your
doctor where they take their cut and
they price gouge you that's not every
industry that would fall into that
category I think there are many
Industries where
um capitalism and and competition works
out for the better for people yeah um
this is just not one of those Industries
and I think the evidence bears that out
so okay so so
um nationalized college so I guess the
question goes back to the following if I
got a billion dollars and you have a
choice between a given a billion dollars
to a free enterprise okay let's give a
billion dollars to Elon let's give a
billion dollars to musk I'm sorry to
Bezos let's give a billion dollars to
whoever that's in the free market take
any of the top 200 guys that made it
from zero to there okay give billion
dollars to them versus giving a billion
dollars to the US government say here go
see what you can do with a billion
dollars who do you trust will do more
with that billion dollars well it
depends on the topic right so uh I would
give the money to the government when it
comes to Pharmaceuticals because a lot
of people don't know this but for the
past two decades there hasn't been a
single drug that hasn't been developed
with government grant money so basically
the government steps in gives money to
universities and says hey we need this
new drug which does X Y or Z and then
they create it and then you have the
pharmaceutical companies swoop in buy up
the patent rights and then sell it back
to everybody at a profit even though
they didn't fund the research and
development So my answer would be it's a
complicated question and it depends on
the the you know it depends what we're
talking about there are plenty of areas
where I'd say yeah give that money to an
entrepreneur no idea be more specific
give me an idea like I'm actually
curious I'm actually really you're a
smart guy you're a very well read guy
you have strong opinions and this is
your world I'm actually curious enough
so if I gave a billion dollars to public
versus you know a private in what areas
you think so one was pharmaceutical Fair
what else would you think they would do
good versus they would do bad like it's
better to put on a free enterprise well
the other I actually just gave the
example uh before I think with uh like
cars uh the government should have no no
business
yeah of course no business in you know I
don't want the government building like
furniture or some [ __ ] that's something
that's squarely for technology for the
private sector Tech I think is a little
more complicated because a lot of the
products that we use today that we kind
of take for granted like stuff like
these phones a lot of that was
originally developed with funding from
NASA so in some ways the government
actually does Science and Technology
very well but to your point yeah there's
plenty of you know uh entrepreneurs and
and private investors who would probably
do it just as well if not better on some
topics yeah that's the part that it
concerns me you know I'm always I think
everything is incentive based right like
I agree I agree with that it's
motive-based incentive and I think it's
everything parenting relationship you
know when two dates and they're sitting
there saying well what is the incentive
of me working my ass off for you you
know what's the incentive of me having
kids and having my body go through the
mess it's going to go through for you we
may not publicly say it but we're
privately thinking about it as we're
going through this process right so you
said something else earlier with Mitt
Romney yeah I want everybody to start at
the same level when they get started
right versus it's not fair that Mitt
Romney's kid or Mitt Romney is a bad
example we can use anybody's kids Paris
Hilton Paris Hilton exactly that's a
great example that's the better example
actually to say you know it's not fair
who is she who all of a sudden hey I'm
doing the documentary people want to
watch me look how cool I am
Etc et cetera okay so what should it be
so let's just say I am uh uh the Hilton
family and we got two and a half billion
dollars right money how much of that
[ __ ] end up going to Paris well that's a
that's a good question I think that
needs to be debated by the people and
determined by the people but if you're
asking my personal opinion I want to
know you yeah my personal opinion uh I
think I wouldn't go as far as some of
the revolutionaries to say like she
should literally start with nothing and
inherit nothing I think that's far too
extreme uh but I wouldn't lose a wink of
sleep if she went from having 2.2
billion dollars to let's say having 50
million dollars I think Paris 99 I I and
honestly I think if you this exact
example I think is a good example where
a lot of people would see where I'm
coming from whereas there's others where
it might be a little more go tell you I
say what give your argument I gotta
follow-up today no I mean because uh
people okay because the way we think of
the economy we we think of it some
people do I should be clear as like it's
a very it's a merit-based thing it's a
meritocracy yeah I don't buy that at all
I think your human value versus your
market value are totally separate things
and we judge everything based on market
value so somebody like Paris Hilton you
know what has she contributed to the
world she's contributed nothing and
we're gonna feel bad if she inherits 50
million dollars and that's just because
people would look at it on paper and say
well her dad had 2.2 billion or whatever
the [ __ ] and it's like I think she's
going to be okay with 50 million I think
the people that I'm concerned about are
the people who are busting their ass and
getting absolutely nowhere people who
work two or three full-time jobs and
they don't make enough money to survive
and I think one of the best groups that
you can tax in a society is Rich dead
people to give everybody else a chance
they do taxed Rich dead people it's
called the estate true but it's very
it's like point zero zero one percent
it's a very very tiny number I think it
kicks in fact check me on this I think
it kicks in over 5 million or 11 million
20 million is 20 million it's been that
well it goes back and forth between uh
different administrations uh Bush pumped
it up but it's very hot right yeah but
still you know what the tax when you
said point one percent that's not what
they're paying in tax no no oh I know
that no I'm saying what percentage of
people are worth 20 million but do you
know what yeah the estate tax actual
amount is do you know the number
so if you're worth 50 million dollars
right there's a 20
uh threshold so that's tax exempt and
now you're paying that 30 additional 30
million additional you have to pay 50 to
the government the death tax number one
you've already been taxed prior to
receiving that money so it's a double
taxation which we can go on for days on
right and how that works so you already
paid the income tax ordinary income tax
or whether it's capital gains what have
you and now speaking of dead people now
you need to pay an additional 50 upon
debt but would you say Paris Hilton
earned it that's my question but that's
not I I don't Paris Hilton she came up
with the word that's hot that went viral
good for her awesome but should the
regardless Paris Hilton is the perfect
poster child for someone who has just
lucked out and got the money correct
when I say we stay on the story okay
this is good and that's fine yeah yeah
but should the Hilton family that
created Industries hotels jobs you know
brands everything are you saying that
they should be taxed at 99 forget about
Paris or Nikki or whatever brother or
sister who cares the only reason we know
their names because she's famous and
she's gonna you know had the the ability
to leverage her name to become famous
and kudos for her for that but you're
saying that the family should be taxed
because they've done so well in this
instance I'm specifically talking about
Paris and how much money I think she
could get and clearly I'm pulling this
number out of my ass because you know
okay to come up with a number on the
spot for because I don't know I actually
don't know how much money her family had
I don't know how much money yeah this
isn't I think the audience knows that we
we're just having to come yeah no I
understand yeah yeah so but but I think
my point is the fact that she's
inheriting 50 million dollars when her
only contribution to society is that
she's part of the lucky sperm club like
I don't feel bad for you and I don't
think she's a victim I don't think she's
oppressed yeah I think if Paris Hilton
got 50 million dollars she wouldn't lose
a wink of sleep and we could actually
and there's the more important point
take the money that we're taxing and
under a system that I'm in control of if
I was God Emperor King right what I
would do is I would take that money and
put it towards things that actually but
how people now how much will that
movement of agreement let me come to a
point of agreement with you though I
would agree with you if you say hey
let's do this tax on Paris right now I
would say well I need to see where that
money is actually going to go what are
we going to allocate that money to
because if you say I'm going to take
that money I'm going to turn around and
use it to bomb Afghanistan into
Smithereens and I say you know what
we're right we probably shouldn't do
that plan because I don't want that
money going to bomb poor innocent kids
but if you tell me we're going to take
that money and put it towards whatever
fill in the blank a Ubi program
Healthcare then I'd say yeah that makes
sense so then the challenge with that
becomes you're going back to ESG it's a
form of ESG to control where my money
goes to and somebody may say who the
hell are you to decide where my money
should go to but this is a different
follow-up question I got for you the
final question I got for you is the
final one you have uh uh you have three
kids yes
are you planning on having more kids
yourself we don't know okay let's just
say you do or you don't we have three
kids okay what percentage of what you
know
are you willing to share with your kids
what percentage of my knowledge yeah
your knowledge your life experience I'd
share it all with them if I could that's
not fair that we should tax it knowledge
is not the same as well but it is though
I wouldn't say that let me explain to
you why it is I mean are you kidding me
like if if I was a kid and I was every
night I come home and I'm having a every
night I come home and I'm having dinner
with you and you're asking me all these
tough questions and we're getting into
it you know what you're doing to my
brain I mean are you kidding me my brain
is getting sharper just by being your
kid because I have to be sharp to be
your kid you're going to challenge me
you're going to push back you're going
to say why do you think this what about
this and have you don't know do you know
the story about this here versus another
person that is raised by a simple father
that doesn't have your kind of knowledge
that kid's like yeah we never talked
about that kind of stuff we just talked
about basic stuff so to me if I have the
edge of a father like you I think that
is also unfair to say well you can pass
down to wisdom and the knowledge that
you have which is way more because
you're more well-read than the average
father we should tax some of that
knowledge and only 20 of it goes to your
kids or five percent of it goes to your
kids because two kids comparing a parent
that is not as knowledgeable as you
versus another one that is at 18 years
old we're not having a fresh start your
kids got an edge over my kid because
your kid has got a little bit more
challenging conversations at night uh
than others do you know like the
Kennedy's families their tradition was
at night they would sit down and have
debates and they would have
conversations I think that is a very
very big yet so but I think you ought to
be able to pass on anything you want to
pass down to your kids even if it's all
the knowledge and the wisdom that you
have so at it just out of curiosity
let's say I'm let's say take me out of
the equation let's just use an example
of somebody who's probably closer to
this but let's say Elon Musk becomes a
trillionaire when Elon Musk dies should
he be able to pass a trillion dollars to
his kids well he won't because he'll pay
the estate tax no but I'm asking you in
your ideal system if I told you in my
ideas
so of that trillion what do those kids
get but let's let's just say the whole
thing let's say let's say it's he's
worth three trillion now which is very
likely for him towards three trillion
hours and the reason why I'm using three
fifty percent is still going to be a
trillion dollars going to the kids right
a trillion and I've gone to the kids
yeah I think yes because a couple
different reasons all of it let me
explain to you listen of course because
because to me uh so you ever been to the
Hearst Castle or you've been to uh what
is that one Castle in California what is
the J Paul getting Museum I don't know
if you've been to the Jay Paul getting
me zoom in La it's really cool if you
ever go to La it's off to 453 but it's a
really cool place to go to okay what
this guy had five kids I I don't know
the exact numbers but he left his kids
only a million dollars a piece okay and
he took the rest of the money and he put
it in an account and the interest on
that account gave the world a a free
museum so when you go there you don't
pay for it it's a free museum and by the
way it's a sick place on a sick location
where you go up and you takes you up the
only thing you pay for is parking for
your car you don't pay anything else is
when you go there okay
get the pictures get the whole nine free
that was part of his cause that's what
he wanted to do he only gave his kids a
million dollars now you know you the
other day we did a uh course on
generational wealth
Vanderbilt they gave their money to
their kids do you know the Vanderbilt's
wealth only lasted two generations like
when Anderson Cooper's mother sat down
with them and said hey Anderson Cooper I
know where Vanderbilt but you know how
to trust fund baby there is no money to
be given to you got to figure out how to
make your money what event what did
Anderson Cooper do make 200 million
dollars of his own money he went to work
he went to work but he's bad at his job
by the way I just throwing that out
there but you know what you know he went
and made his money and you know he
probably used a little bit of the last
Sim in the connections and all that but
then some of the families the money's
been kept for six seven generations
Medici you can look at some of these
other ones love them or hate them
they've kept the money in their family
whether it's Rothschilds Koch brothers
these are some of the most hated people
in the world because the money's been
passed down and the the the general
feeling of dude I got started and I had
nothing you already rich just because
your last name is XYZ I think it's the
parents decision to do what they want to
do with the money unfortunately most of
the parents don't make the right
decision on how they give the money to
the kids nowadays there's a lot of
difference there's a company called
Ronald blue that helps you set up a
state planning and it's so funny to have
a meeting with your kids
and they'll say listen you guys are the
kolinsky family great job your family
has an estate for you to participate in
the estate you have to do the following
if you don't you don't get any of it if
you do it goes you get this much by 30
This Much by 35 that much by 40 This
Much by 45 This Much by 50 the most
responsible one if you qualify we'll run
the companies if you're not and you're
doing stupid things you won't be running
the companies Etc et cetera et cetera I
think the parents who screw up with the
money that kid is not going to keep the
money anyways they're going to spend the
hell out of the money it's not hard to
spend 300 million dollars if a kid is a
dumb kid they'll spend the money like
this but if the parents have done proper
State planning that kid has to keep
working and doing it right to
participate in a portion of that money
there's a way to put in to say you have
to give this much your money away every
year you have to give that much away you
have to do this you have to do that so
there is a lot of this one right here
this is one I can't even believe I'm
giving these guys an endorsement you
guys do actually very good job with
their business but there's a lot of
companies like this to do that so for me
to you yes I would say it's the parents
decision to do whatever they want to do
all right so but let's go back to the
original example of Elon because I have
a what I think is a very difficult
question for you so you said let's argue
hypothetically he's worth three trillion
dollars uh you know in my world I think
a significant amount of that would be
taxed and his kids would be fine they'd
get millions but you know I wouldn't I
don't want to pass 3 trillion to them
um and look it's a scale right some
people would revolutionaries would go as
far as to say like attacks the whole
shebang and then people on the other
side would say yeah no don't don't tax
it at all
um but what if I told you what if there
was a program we're going to tax that
three trillion dollars uh let's just
make up some numbers here let's say a
trillion of the 3 trillion is is taken
by the government but let's say every
dollar of that trillion dollars goes to
a program which helps eliminate homeless
veterans in America would you say yeah
that's a program I could get behind does
he choose to do that no it wouldn't it
would be government I'm not a force guy
I'm a choice guy that's the problem so
there's no so what tax are you okay with
any taxes no I'm okay I'm okay with some
taxes
like what percentage or um well yeah
what percentage well we don't need to
get into percentages but what kind of is
it like sales tax income tax what taxes
do you think are okay if I had it my way
I would like a flat tax if I had in my
way I prefer flat tax where everybody's
being taxed the same exact wage so it's
in an income tax but it's a flat rate
yeah but and by the way this is for me
to disagree with a Ronald Reagan who
likes the progressive idea a lot of
conservatives are progressive I'm more
flat tax I'm more you know allowing for
example Dave Forbes yeah I I think a
flat tax model what would you do like 15
what 15 points is good yeah because the
issue with the flat tax in theory I
agree with you that in theory it sounds
you know it's appealing but the problem
with that is effectively it's a
regressive tax which means it hits the
poor more because right now there's
about 50 percent of the country that
doesn't make enough money to pay any
federal taxes zero I actually disagree
because if there's a flat tax a lot of
the billionaires that are not paying
right now would have to pay because it's
flat tax so that's true but on the other
end you'd have these people 50 of the
country is basically paying no federal
taxes they'd have to pay 15 of their
income they can't afford to do there
should be a threshold so let me give you
less I'll give you I'll give you I'll
give you the idea here on this part this
is the one side of the argument with
taxes that I haven't shared with you so
you remember when uh uh when Andrew Yang
came out with the ubis well this is what
Milton Friedman said and NADA you know
it's I'm just doing with Milton Friedman
proposed you know Milton Friedman came
up with the negative negative income tax
you know which you have to work to earn
it and then up to this point we would
help you out with the 50 but you gotta
also contribute to society so subsidize
the lower end absolutely I I actually to
me I'm the earned the right to vote earn
the right everything to me is earned the
right go earn the right to be able to do
XYZ you contribute to society in
whatever way you want to contribute to
society you get a louder mic you don't
contribute to society you shouldn't be
able to have a louder mic if I'm one of
your kids you got four kids let's just
say
and they all decide to live in your
house they're all above 18. like that I
want to live with you I love you so much
I want to live with you if one of the
three kids one of the four kids isn't
paying rent and so it's the second
oldest one should he have amount of the
same amount of say as the youngest one
that's paying rent to you on a monthly
basis no the youngest one is saying that
I'll pay a thousand dollars a month
because I got a job the second oldest
one's like nah I just want to chill out
I don't want to pay anything and he
parties his ass off or he doesn't want
to get to work go apply for a job nobody
wants to hire me you haven't applied for
something for six months what do you
mean nobody wants to hire you I have a
very big problem with that person having
a voice in that house saying what to do
you haven't earned the right to have a
voice so the issue with like earning the
right to vote is that if you look at the
you know old school Jim Crow South they
had this thing like you have to do a
poll test to show that you're a good
citizen that you understand the country
before you can vote and that was just
like a stealth way to try to take away
the vote from poor people and from
minorities so I mean look we live in a
country there's going to be some
percentage of the country they're just
[ __ ] idiots but that doesn't mean you
could you know take away their their
basic rights so I think that you know
everybody as long as they're over a
certain age I think they deserve the
right to vote if that's the standard if
that's the standard that we set then yes
you're right the the some people will be
[ __ ] idiots if you're gonna say
that's the standard but if the standard
is to set and say hey look I'm not
asking you to be a millionaire I'm not
asking to be a billionaire I'm not
asking to go be a CEO what I am asking
for is go contribute to society I don't
care what it is if you contribute to
society I'm all in I'm not gonna judge
you if you're making 48 000 a year I'm
not going to judge you if you're making
700 000 a year what I will respect is
the fact that you are contributing to
society yesterday we're staying at the
Comfort Inn
and it's one lady we start talking to
her so you know hey she asked us how was
Christmas great we had a great Christmas
we're all downstairs on the lobby I'm
trying to do the zoom and we're having a
regular breakfast at Comfort Inn you
already know what the breakfast is going
to look like it's not a crazy breakfast
this one girl I can tell you the tattoo
she had on her neck on her hand she's
cleaning up everywhere like you wouldn't
believe yes I was you I was this oh my
God it was great well my boyfriend and I
tried to go to Christmas together but we
couldn't because we had an issue so we
have to spend time together we didn't go
to my parents house
and then hey do you have a straw she
goes upstairs grabs a straw of her mom's
and she says I washed it everything I
know it's not a uh it's a used straw but
I cleaned it for you do you want to use
this for your kid because you know our
baby only and my nanny's like very uh
sensitive with stuff it's like no I'm
not gonna use that straw
and rather than given an attitude she
says no problem I'll be back the girl
gets in the car goes to her place brings
two straws that are covered with the you
know the whole thing around it and she
says here so where'd you get that from I
went home and got it for you you're
kidding me no do you know how much
respect I got for that person that's
working at that Comfort absolutely you
know what I did to her I gave her
attention we can't accept tips I said
well I want to leave this money here
don't take it if you don't want to this
money is staying here so you can either
leave it here or someone's gonna take it
so well that that's the case I'll take
the money so you've earned the right I
value service I have the same amount of
respect for that girl to giving me that
kind of service and the guy that pulls
up in a Lamborghini who's making 20
million a year because you're
contributing to society when you say
there's going to be a lot of messed up
people in America I have a problem
making that be okay rather than
challenging them to say go contribute
even if it's this much for that woman
let's say you were somebody else and
you're kind of an [ __ ] and she gives
amazing amazing service and then they
don't tip at all
what would you say about her shouldn't
she get a raise shouldn't she be paid
more up front because I have a problem
with the minimum you know the exception
to the minimum wage rules where it's
like well we have this minimum wage but
then if you work in this industry or
that industry you actually make less
than the minimum wage and then you have
to earn it in tips I think in many
instances like [ __ ] yeah you can
make you can make you can literally work
full-time and then not make enough money
to survive I don't think that should be
a thing I think if you're into your
point I think that if you're if you're
running a respectable business like you
need to earn the right to be in business
and that means you need to pay your
people if they're working full-time
enough to get by but if you don't
somebody else will so that's the great
thing about capitalism crack down on the
people who are are cheating in the
system who are fraudulent I don't think
but I don't think they survived Kyle I
don't know many of them do no they don't
they don't survive you don't think there
are any companies that pay less than a
living wage they do but they can't keep
good people though they can't keep good
good pick out listen how how long if if
you're in a you ever been in a
relationship where a person didn't value
you oh absolutely what'd you do
eventually we left it okay have you ever
been the [ __ ] to her I'm sure I have
I have two and what and what did she do
she left you and I sure but the point is
people eventually leave [ __ ] okay
like this isn't like you know where
we're living in the Middle East and you
have you know it's a sweatshop in China
no this this is America in America you
have choices you have options so even if
the guy doesn't pay well you leave if
they don't leave here's what's the worst
thing that happens can you pull up the
story with what McDonald's just did the
first full-on automated I don't know if
you saw this or not that's a you know
showing what it's doing they're gonna go
automated and they're going to say but
so but here's the thing I think they're
going to do that anyway I think we're
moving anyway I do as well so then we
need to find a way to ameliorate when it
goes to when the bottom floor falls out
from underneath everybody who's already
struggling and it gets even worse we
need to find a way to ameliorate that
we're going to be dealing with real
civil unrest the likes of which we
haven't seen in our lifetime see see for
me uh uh on the first question by the
way you know when you when I said people
are going to leave and find another job
here's here's uh for me okay uh I think
the the message that Bernie has I I I
just so you know I trust Bernie
a hundred times more than I trust Biden
yeah because I think he's authentic
because I believe him right you believe
he's a True Believer I see you know what
I respect you right on what you're
saying I can sit there and listen to a
person and say I respect the fact that
you fully believe in what you're talking
about I don't see Bernie as a
manipulator right I don't I see Bernie
that maybe hey you know what let's pay
minimum wage should be this much and
then he was paying one of his interns 12
bucks and he came out [ __ ] we screwed up
I didn't know about it okay every none
of us is walking on water my standard
isn't walking on water I'm not going to
sit there and say well he look at him
you know we should tax the millionaires
now he's taxing a billionaires because
he's now millionaire fine totally get it
so the markers moving a little bit more
it's always taxed to people that are a
little bit richer than me that's a
little bit of the contradiction that
comes with the taxes but going back to
this part this is my challenge here's my
challenge my challenge becomes Kyle
um in our house the currency is reading
books pages so if you read you're able
to have leverage to ask me for things
okay if you're one of my kids the moment
you turn six years old you have to read
20 Pages a day you read 20 Pages a date
you can ask for things you read 20 Pages
a day you get iPad every weekend for one
hour okay you're able to watch TV and
movies on the weekend okay you read 20
Pages a day you're able to ask XYZ every
quarter okay you read 20 the currency is
reading so we're having this game we're
playing Scrabble and my kids are able to
come up with all these different words
because these kids read okay we're
playing this uh Jeopardy type of a game
questions did you know this all of them
I could answer so I'm like what I never
knew that how did you learn about that
well because I read XYZ he's read like
500 who HQ books by 10 years old I think
I come to you versus I go to him
and both of you guys are my uncle and
I'm his son okay hypothetically
so I go to Adam and I say Adam I gotta
tell you man I'm so sick of my dad Rob
it's just I'm so sick of it he wants me
to do this he wants me to do that he
wants me to eat this he wants me to
train like this he wants me to read this
book I'm so freaking tired of my dad
Adam says the following he says Ah your
dad's been annoying for his entire life
he's my brother I've known him he's
annoying just be patient when you're 18
get the hell away from him as quickly as
possible okay you shouldn't have to work
that hard that's not fair you're just a
kid why is he pushing you so hard that's
not what he should be doing a lot of
people disagree with your dad but
unfortunately there's nothing we can do
about it right now okay that's one Uncle
now I go to his other brother it's you
I'm saying Uncle Kyle my dad is this my
dad is that he's so annoying and he say
just be lucky that's your dad okay
because he's raising a leader one day
you're gonna do this one day you're
gonna do that one day you're gonna do
this I would be very grateful that you
have the dad that you have
there's two philosophies in America
right now one is feeling sorry for you
constantly the other one is telling you
step up and lead and do something about
it I like this more because it's keeping
less people dependent on a system this
is keeping more people dependent on the
system this mindset increases taxes this
mindset decreases taxes what are your
thoughts on that so first of all let me
just be clear I've never met a tax cut
for the working class that I didn't love
I love cutting taxes on Working Class
People so I'm not talking I'd give them
even more money right so what I'm
talking about is more on the topic you
know what I'm talking I'm talking about
contributing no I understand that but
let me just address the point because I
think there's an important counter
argument which is
I don't think a system can justify
somebody working full-time and then they
don't get paid enough money to even
survive I think that system has failed
to prove itself as being the best system
to your point my in fact I almost agree
with your point maybe more than you do
because I want to reward the hard work
and my point is I feel like the hard
work is not being rewarded right now
because I think like I think like
basically 95 of the country is trying
their hardest and in many instances just
treading water in the same place and not
getting I don't know if it's 95 but but
I think majority are I don't think right
okay so we have broad agreement on that
yes yeah no I do but but here here's the
part so when you're talking about you
know uh uh if a person's working a
full-time job and they're not able to
pay the bills I don't think that's fair
okay fine let's no no you're saying that
no no no I don't know
oh look we've made it I'm not agreeing
but this is now you know what I would
say here's what I would say to the door
okay here's what I would say to them
uh there was a time my market value was
375 an hour and they probably overpaid
you know when they were paying me 375 an
hour because I was not a good employee
okay there was a time my market value
was six bucks an hour okay when I worked
at Burger King I was 475 an hour okay
when I worked at Valley Total Fitness it
was 720 an hour that's what they paid me
that was the market value for me because
the military paid me Pennies on a dollar
because the military you're working 100
hours a week so they're not paying you a
lot of money you make 800 bucks a month
you're broke
so when I'm sitting there at Bally's and
I'm making seven bucks an hour okay and
I'm broke and I can't do anything you
know what I would do on my break I
always had a book I read so I would sit
they would make fun of me I would sit
there and I'm reading a book I'm a 1.8
GPA guy okay I'm not a guy that's a
reading guy I'm a guy that started first
book I ever finished in my life cover to
cover I was 21 years old first book I
ever finished I was 21 years old so I'm
sitting there
and
on my break this guy named Jose who was
my boss he would come and make fun of me
he'll say Patrick what are you doing you
believe in this dream type of stuff of
being a millionaire do you realize I
make eighty thousand dollars a year I
drive a nice BMW I got a great life you
think these books are going to change
your life and I'm like listen man I have
no desire to make eighty thousand
dollars because that's a tough life for
me I saw what my mom and dad did I don't
want to do what you're doing you're
clubbing five nights a week you're on
your third marriage I just don't want
that life I told him straight up he's
like what so I don't want your life it's
that simple I just don't want your life
and I think there's a lot of people that
don't want that life but rather than
saying I think it's unfair that these
people are making only this much and
they can barely pay their pay their
bills my question to them is what are
you doing to increase your market value
if you increase your for example you're
using an iPhone right why don't you use
a Blackberry why don't you use an old
Nextel why don't you use a Nokia why do
you use a Blackberry why do you use an
iPhone it's pretty arbitrary I just
whatever phone fell in mind I don't
think that's the case though I don't
think that's the case things don't even
they're not really sold anymore anyway
some of them are some of the shitty
phones are still around but the point is
the following you need that phone
because you need to check your creative
Studios you need to check YouTube you
need to get back on Twitter your your
personality people want to see what you
have to say so that phone has made the
best argument to you as a market value
that's why you're using that for not
some of the older phones I think the
same way Apple has made the argument to
you to use their phone it's the same way
a lot of people need to sit there and
say well maybe my market value is only
forty two thousand dollars here see I
don't I don't disagree with you though
that's the thing I think we're talking
past each other because if your argument
is if I boil it down to its simplest
form if your argument is look try your
best don't stop trying learn
um keep reading keep expanding your
horizons don't take no for an answer uh
keep grinding if that's your message we
have total agreement because I see
nothing wrong with that at all in fact I
would also look I like to dabble every
now and then as well into the you know
listening to various self-help stuff
listen to a motivational rant sometimes
it gets me fired up sometimes I listen
I'm like let's let's [ __ ] go let's do
this thing so we don't disagree at all I
think the only area of disagreement we
have is that even if we had a society
where literally 100 of people did what
you're recommending there the problem is
that the system itself does not reward
that inherently so we could still have
10 million people living in abject
poverty and be working poor so they're
still trying but they still just get a
bad roll the dice and they don't get far
enough that's the thing that I'm focused
on in terms of the system and how to fix
it in terms of the individual you and I
have total agreement because of course I
I would give people I would give the
people in my life personally and you
know to my audience I'd give them the
exact same advice you just gave which is
and by the way how do you think I made
it on YouTube in the first place well
you think I'm just better than everybody
my personality is just like oh that guy
is so Dynamic work your ass off he's
gonna yeah I kept showing up right I
kept showing up
for the first year and a half or two
years I had nobody's [ __ ] watching I
had nobody watching me there was
probably less than 20 people with their
eyeballs on me for my show when I was
doing a two or three hour show every
single day so yeah I think we agree more
than more than uh we recognized I just I
just think that message we we
collectively need to give that message
more because I think what you've done
okay let me ask you Kyle uh uh if if a
thousand people out there want to do
what Kyle's doing okay unless you say
out of these thousand people they're
paying their their interest is not
politics one guy's interest is
basketball right but very good like
follows everything to basketball one is
movies and it's a great movie critic
right one is food recipes one is you
know writing one is math whatever it is
right everybody has something to offer
to the to society
do you think if they
apply themselves and work the way you
have and stay disciplined the way you
have you think they could also
eventually make it I think a certain
percentage of them but I think if I'm if
I'm guessing maybe
15 only 15 would make it if they did
what you did 20. well yeah well I think
it's very highly obviously okay what do
you say like four 400 people I said a
thousand people okay a thousand people
yeah I think look
the the harsh truth of the world how
many videos have you uploaded how many
videos have you uploaded tens of
thousands bro you're saying like you're
saying like what you've done is easy all
I'm saying to you is if anybody goes out
there how much material do you read to
stay on top to endless from when I wake
up to when I go okay so if I do yeah
what you do in my space of specialty I'm
a Disney guy I'm a business guy I'm a
sports guy I'm a art guy I'm a you know
scam guy like I study all the scams
because there's great YouTube channels
that do I'm I'm a guy that does what
they do but if I study the way you study
and research and I put 10 000 videos on
YouTube don't you think I'm eventually
gonna make it in my specialty it's not a
guarantee and that's the that's the sad
reality I think that you disagree with
that do you disagree with that but but
let me say what I mean like okay so it's
very hard to debate this from your
perspective here's okay uh do you work
out you're a good looking guy I don't
know I did for quite a while okay now so
I do the Trump workout regimen because I
play golf Trump
okay so so let me ask you this let me
ask you this we got a thousand people
we're gonna play this game in a
different way we got a thousand people
if we have a thousand people who agreed
okay to stop eating bread stop eating
sugar okay and they got one cheat day a
month not even a week they got one cheat
month whatever you want per month but
for 29 days you're straight up clean
they did cardio three times a week 30
minutes and they went to the gym and
they did weights for 45 minutes four
times a week if a thousand people did it
they're all losing weight they're all
losing every single one of them Point
what I'm trying to say is if people
followed your methodology of researching
reading working ten thousand busting
their ass when no one's watching them
they're eventually going to win because
that's the that's how formulas work I
understand that I guess the core of our
disagreement though is how much can be
attributed to nurture slash environment
versus nature and I think the core of
our disagreement here is especially when
it comes to this particular field of
YouTube we all know people let's keep it
real there are people who have
effectively anti-charisma sometimes P
there are some people who talk and you
go they have that X Factor I listen to
them and I'm like I want to listen to
every [ __ ] word they say and then
there's some people where the second
they open
yeah it's called a high tune-out fact
yeah we're familiar with that around
here one of the biggest YouTubes right
now blowing up is ran by a guy that has
no he's not a Charisma I get it look
he's not a Charisma no no but
he does have he does have his own
Charisma I'll disagree with you on that
because and I think Noam Chomsky too
agree or disagree with him he makes
monotone sounds I've had them on I've
had them on Lex makes uh monotone sound
good yeah yeah but I don't think you're
smart you know what's crazy like I've
been in sales for 21 years
what I used to judge as somebody that's
going to be a great salesperson I failed
miserably let me explain to you why so I
would see a guy I'm like oh my God this
guy's personality is freaking class this
guy's gonna blow up he's going to make
millions right officers like no he
didn't he was lazy and then I had a guy
that was a terrible accent from stage he
would say the key to success is you
gotta Focus
what you gotta [ __ ] gentlemen do [ __ ]
it for success
by the way if he ever writes a book he's
got to write a book since the key is
[ __ ] is right
f-u-c-k-i-s but what he's trying to say
is you gotta Focus right yeah yeah yeah
and then he would go and talk to
families you half the time you would
learn something but it wasn't like he
was as charismatic as the other guy but
the guy was willing to do the work all
I'm saying Kyle to you is the following
all I'm saying is I think
when people come up to me and they say
you know well you don't understand the
challenges if you don't understand the
life family you don't understand how
hard it is I like how many books have
you read in the last six months what
course are you taking to improve
yourself what are you doing to get
better and if the answer is no you know
every yeah I have a problem with that I
I think daggeration needs to be held
accountable yeah I agree I mean look I
think the problem is we're having two
separate conversations I think there's
one conversation about the system and
how we address the system then there's a
whole other conversation about at the
individual level how do you treat people
what values do you impart on them and I
think on the values front on the
individual front we agree 100 because
yeah you should focus you should try to
create a culture of hard work you should
try to create a culture of people
showing up being passionate about
something giving their all to something
uh it's just in my in my view it's just
two separate conversations where you
could also have a separate conversation
about what do we do with the system what
do we do with the tax rates what do we
do with the living wage law what do we
do about unions and so that's that's
where our disconnect is coming from well
let's if you want to go there because I
want to go to a different topic yeah
well I just want to kind of revisit
where how this whole conversation
started because I obviously we're trying
to find some common ground here but
going back to I I think what you stand
for with the social democracy is you
ever seen that that video where like you
know dozens of kids line up for a race
and like there's the coach being like
all right take two steps forward if
you're if your parents are still married
and then kids take two steps forward all
right take uh a step forward if you've
graduated high school boom and then
you've seen this thing before I don't
know if you can pull that up but you
know basically it's an expose on however
you were raised or whatever the merits
you had or the benefits you had you're
going to have a leg up in life right so
all right so
essentially the message was a lot of the
the black kids or the Latino kids or you
know poor kids even poor white kids for
that matter this understanding how
privilege works okay just just interject
I'm sorry I hate the like privilege
discourse just totally agree I'm with
you on this but all these kids start
taking a step forward okay great so
you're sort of your Baseline is you want
everybody to start at the same starting
point and just have a a fair starting
point a fair no advantages for certain
kids over the others and you talk about
health care uh free college student
loans uh credit cards but isn't that
kind of the antithesis of America
because hear me out you're you're a
byproduct of what your parents decide to
do so if your parents work hard pay
their bills is that right I think it is
right really so if my parents are
scoundrel drunk then I'm just destined
to be [ __ ] and that's fine I'm not why
are you destined to be [ __ ] you can
make a decision to to actually clean up
your act you don't have to live because
your parents [ __ ] up but if Pat
basically spent his whole life reading
books working out improving raises kids
the right way made millions and hundreds
of millions of dollars and Rob over here
worked a nine to five didn't read books
didn't improve didn't pass down anything
knowledge wealth to his kids are you
saying that Rob's kid should have the
exact same starting point as Pat's kids
I think that's utterly unfair okay
so first of all you said like this is
you know kind of the antithesis of
America I totally disagree with that
because when you look at civil rights
history that was the core of what they
were trying to do hey it's unfair that
we have our boot on the neck of this
entire class of people they're you know
minorities and they're treated unfairly
let's just start treating them fairly
that was the core of that and also the
New Deal that was FDR coming in and
saying you know what these what he
called economic royalists have been
[ __ ] working people for far too long
you know the the income and wealth
inequality at the time was Preposterous
it was called the robber baron era
because you had this top tiny sliver of
the population that was making all the
[ __ ] money then you had these people
who were working all day every day with
[ __ ] pay Industrial Revolution
Aristocrats Fat Cats yeah all that stuff
and so 150 years ago so what I would
argue is I I think what I'm trying to do
is harness the best of the American
tradition I think that social democracy
is America at its best that's what
Social Security was Medicare Medicaid
these basic programs to say I want
people to have a fair shot it's more I
think you're focusing more on the you
know let's like punish the Mitt Romney
types or whatever where my point is no
Let's Help the people at the bottom to
get to a reasonable floor can I respond
sure 100 years ago FDR you know
Industrial Revolution everything that
Rockefellers even up to civil rights
dude I think your argument is completely
Fair meaning like of course right right
certain people were screwed but it's
been 50 plus years since then at what
point do we acknowledge you know what
people there's no systematic racism at
this point there's no the man keeping
people down Barack Obama became a
president things have changed is what
I'm saying we're not back in the 1910s
OR 1870s or even the 1960s where people
didn't get a fair Shake I think more
than ever people have the fairest Shake
they've ever had in this world so at
what point does does that argument kind
of get does get quelled meaning like all
right we've addressed it you're right
Kyle 50 years ago your argument held
water like crazy does it still hold the
same water today though yes it does you
know what the number one cause of
bankruptcy in America is medical debt
correct yeah you think that makes sense
I don't but but so wait so just let's
just focus on that for a second so we
agree on that one so that same spirit
that we brought to the Civil Rights
fight to the New Deal fight we need
there's going to come a time when people
look back at our era let's say 50 years
in the future 100 years in the future
and they go these [ __ ] psychos were
just sitting around when people were
dying left and right and drowning up
drowning up to their eyeballs in medical
debt and 45 000 people dying because
they didn't have basic health care
there's going to come a time where we
look at that with the same kind of scorn
that we looked at segregation in the Jim
Crow South yeah and that's what I'm just
trying to I don't know if it'll be that
level but however the question is the
question stands and and Bernie did a
great job of this
um you know this is the question of is
Healthcare a right or is it a privilege
right and then should the government pay
for everything every time the government
gets involved in something that's going
to get [ __ ] but then you have these
monopolies these uh Tech biotech
companies you know big farm Irma that
are making you know across state lines
this whole valid argument but at the end
of the day you know who's paying for all
this right so the scan you bring up the
Scandinavian countries you know how many
people live in all of Scandinavia all of
Scandinavia Sweden Denmark Norway
Iceland Greenland how many people you
think yeah it's not many I know it's
like 20 million people I understand that
okay there's more people in Texas and in
Florida and California we've got 20 to
40 million so I don't know if that
argument is can extrapolate because
number one each of those countries
operate independently so it's 5 million
a piece versus 350 million here I just
don't know how it's going to work and
who's going to pay for it all Bernie
Sanders to my final point if you were
just
going based on personality and rhetoric
people are like this guy is awesome he's
crazy he's wild his crazy hair he's got
he's got that Pizzazz Charisma but then
when you gotta actually do the math it's
like how the [ __ ] is Bernie going to pay
all this okay same with AOC in the new
green deal so the problem is a lot of
people will be like yes Bernie's the man
of course attacks the billionaires but
it's like all right well where's this
money actually going how are we gonna
fund all this that's the problem I think
people have is like great ideas where's
the math coming to okay so there's some
very simple answers to that first of all
there was a report that just came out
not too long ago in the responsible
statecraft Outlet uh the Pentagon just
failed its fifth audit in a row they
cannot account for I believe the number
was 59 of their funds
now somebody might want to check you
know Dick Cheney's [ __ ] wallet and
somebody might want to check what was
going on at Halliburton Brown and root
and all these Raytheon Boeing we spent
over a trillion dollars I think it's
actually close to two trillion dollars
on this plane called the F-35 II which
doesn't even [ __ ] fly right to this
day okay so when you say man how are we
gonna pay for that's my first answer is
we if we did you know if we cut our
military budget and I'm not exaggerating
here by 50 we would still have the
biggest military in the world by far and
it's not even close okay so how much is
our military budget uh so it there's the
on the books answer then there's the off
the books answer the um go on the books
yeah the on the books answer is about
850 billion dollars okay how much so do
you know what percentage I think 90 of
our budget goes to
yeah well that entitlement programs
that's where all our money is going
all of it well again defense is like
five ten percent at that a lot of people
want to say all right if you cut a
couple hundred billion here there's
trillions and trillions and trillions go
to Social Security Medicare Medicaid so
that's where our the entirety of our
budget is going and it's getting larger
and larger as Boomers you know 10 000
Baby Boomers turn 65 every single day
like what do you want to do with those
programs so first of all those Pro those
those programs there's the defense
there's the discretionary portion of the
budget and and the non-discretionary
portion of the budget and those are
viewed as kind of off the table nobody
touches this in other words you don't
need Washington to step in every year to
re-up Social Security Medicare Medicaid
they're sort of off on their own and I
think it's a good thing that they're not
addressed every single year because I
don't think we'd ever [ __ ] renew
health care for old people or or
payments for old people
um I like those programs and those
programs are some of the most popular in
the country I think we should look more
at doing stuff like that and not wasting
a tremendous amount of money blowing up
countries that didn't attack us yeah I
agree but I'm just saying follow the
money but the majority of the money it's
easy easy to go deep no one here is
going to be like yes keep just pouring
money into defense and it's without
reason I think we're all on the same
page there I I think Pat might because
he's a former Army might say we need
America we talk about how many bases
America has across the world yeah 800
plus bases where China has won I think
there's been supportive there's a lot of
excessive and Glutton pork belly and all
that stuff that goes into defense but
that's still a small fraction of really
where the budget is going with these
entitlement programs you know Kyle the
the challenge like today if a person
really wanted to run for office and they
got up and they said well listen here's
what we're going to be doing folks
everybody's got to get back to work you
got to do your part you got to improve
some skills you got to learn two or
three skills next 12 months hopefully
five new skills the next two years and
we think you can increase your market
value but we are so much in debt we
can't give any more entitlement programs
we're not going to be doing any more
buildback better nothing for eight years
we're not spending any more money than
we are right now we're in the business
of cutting down expenses today just like
a company we're supposed to cut down
expenses right now we have way too much
debt do you know if somebody ran on that
you know it's the chances of that person
winning no chance probably zero zero
because what's popular today is what
Andrew Yang says what Bernie Sanders
says what Biden says what Elizabeth
Warren says what anybody says that we're
going to give it to you if you vote me
in for free we are more and more and
more gradually becoming an entitled
Nation
and that's a scary thought because
eventually something has to happen with
all this money we can't constantly be
giving money away to people it is very
attractive this is why kids love their
grandparents because grandparents
secretly give chocolate away to kids and
parents don't if I see my daughter what
goodies are people getting like I don't
see the working class is struggling I
just told you 63 of people are living
paycheck to patients and people are
doing they're not in a good place right
now then that tells you we were doing a
shitty job spending people's money goes
back to my point that the money being
given to the government they don't know
what to do with the money because we're
definitely not slowing down giving money
to the government there's another 1.7
trillion dollars last week we're not
like saying no to it here here's more of
our money let's see what you're gonna do
with it they don't do good with it again
let's give you a little bit more money
again they don't do good with it if if
as an investor you deal with your
financial advisor you're gonna have a
financial advisor you probably have a
financial advisor and you're going to
fire some financial advisors okay and
some of them you think a lot about what
they do with your money if you don't
think about what your financial advisor
is doing with your money guess what it's
because he's probably doing a good job
right you're like okay listen I get the
right returns he protects me calls me
saying hey here's what happened I
suggest moving this money from here to
bonds because we think the next six
months going to go this hey I think
we're ready to go into equities are you
comfortable for going to equity is great
and then there are some that never call
you there are people in your life you
trust a waiter you trust hey I like my
St 910 I got you Pat he brings it how is
it good never ask him again because the
guy knows how to make your eyes to your
Arnold Palmer hey here's how I like my
steak medium you ever had to order the
medium and they bring you well done how
annoyed you are when you cut the meat
and you're like dude I said medium this
is well done right you don't trust that
restaurant okay
the government has a very low trust in
the marketplace with what they do with
the money and this doesn't go on Bernie
Sanders because a Bernie Sanders getting
elected isn't all of a sudden going to
clean house with all the employees and
bring in the people that we're going to
trust that's going to do the job because
Bernie's not going to be doing the job
Trump's not gonna it's gonna be the
people on the inside that are going to
be doing the job so that's the challenge
when it goes back to what we do with the
money they have a very low credibility
score of what they do unless we agree
public trust in the government yeah
today let me address this yeah because
on this we 100 agree
um as somebody who believes in social
democracy I mean I think somebody would
have to be high to think that I support
this current government I mean the
problem is from the 1970s until today
there's been a number of Supreme Court
cases which have effectively legalized
bribery legalized corruption
um there was the Buckley versus Vallejo
case the McCutchen case the citizens
united case and this is just fancy legal
speak of saying
um they decided it is uh the same as
free speech rights for a billionaire or
a corporation to donate to politicians
so when you bring up your concern of
like look what the [ __ ] going on with
all this money like they you know the
government keeps doing stuff and people
don't see improvements in their everyday
life I think that's a million percent
correct and the reason is you have the
military industrial complex big Pharma
the for-profit health insurance
companies Wall Street individual
billionaires they pay the politicians
then the politicians turn around and
pass legislation that helps out those
special interests those lobbyists it
doesn't help out the working people so
of course we're we're 100 in agreement
on that and I think the solution on that
front if you want good governance if you
want a government that actually
represents the people more where you can
see it's all accountable and you see
where the money's going and it's all
going to positive places there's
something called clean elections which
effectively is taking the private
financing out of the election system so
no more corporate donations no more
billionaire donations the way it works
is there's a process to determine who
gets on the ballot and then once you're
on the ballot it's uh funded by the
taxpayers and then you have a genuine
real true battle of ideas and policies
and disagreements and it's no longer a
battle of competing factions where for
example it's like well you know the
Democrats are bought by the these this
lawyer group or these unions and the
Republicans are bought by this hedge
fund and and so whoever ends up winning
the election guess who's going to get
served either the hedge fund or the
Earth of course right yes yeah we're on
the same place this is why this is why
um for Trump and Bernie because neither
one of them are bought okay and whatever
they're gonna say is whatever they're
gonna say and they got the voters to
come in we had Paul manafort here I
don't know what it was four months ago
five months ago and I said I don't like
lobbyists because you guys are messing
everything up right yeah you know how
much money these guys make
it's ungodly some of these guys are
making 10 20 million dollars you're
doing what they're doing but here's
here's what one thing uh that's I again
I think we're gonna agree on this one
here so Elon buys Twitter okay which we
haven't even gotten to the Twitter
conversation to see what your thoughts
are on that but Elon buys Twitter they
got 7 500 employees
immediately he cuts 50 so go to 37.50
they cut 37.50 the 37.50 that were cut
recruit the other 1200 to quit so 37.50
gets another 1200 so he's not lost 5 000
okay
7 500 employees to 2500 employees and
Twitter's done more advancement in the
last two months of additional things on
Twitter that you've seen the last two
three years now what do you like the
features or not it's irrelevant it's
things are being updated right it's like
quickly things are being updated Twitter
went from being a slow large you know a
social government social media company
to announce going back to the startup
things moving very very quickly right
the amount of organizations we have in
in the government that have ten thousand
fifty thousand hundred thousand
employees that can be run on a tenth of
that that you're seeing and by the way
uh uh of Facebook other companies are
seeing what Twitter is doing they're
like dude maybe we don't need a hundred
thousand employees maybe we don't need
fifty thousand we don't only why and by
the way these salaries are not like it's
twenty thousand dollar your salary
seventy thousand dollar your salaries
these are guys making 180 150 200 250
000 of your salary so we're also
learning that wasted money in free
enterprise people are starting to
realize we can do more work with fewer
people that's not good for people that
want to raise minimum wage but also in
the government every time we need uh 80
how many thousand IRS agents that they
just hire eighty seven thousand dollars
and they're saying with the 87 by the
way with guns 87 000 IRS agents we're
gonna did you see what number they give
we're gonna be able to collect another
trillion dollars of tax money to be fair
they say that's for people who make 400
000 and over they're saying that they're
saying that but good luck going and
spending some money and getting a 700
bill on something you did on you know
PayPal or any of that stuff you're still
getting that 700 tax bill they're still
going and collecting that money from the
people 87 000 IRS agents for what how
does that sell me to dream how does that
sell me to dream what are you saying to
people we're going to collect money you
really need 87 000 of them well see the
problem is under the previous
administrations I think going all the
way back to Bill Clinton but it may have
been from Obama and onward there's been
effectively like a war on the IRS where
they've fired a tremendous number of
them so getting back these 87 000 is not
even getting back to you know what it
was however many years ago do you think
we need more IRS agencies to go after
the wealthy yeah because right now I
agree with your point about the IRS kind
of harassing working people and going
after people who make forty thousand
dollars a year or whatever it is no I
don't want to go after those people and
I like I told you I think those people
should get a tax cut if anything else I
think they should have more money yes I
definitely think we should reign in the
oligarchs for sure and you need the IRS
well I would Define the old oligarchs as
what we just described before which is
the billionaires and corporations who
pay the government their campaign
contribution 87 000 to go after 500
people well no I mean not just the
oligarchs I'm talking about but that's
which is the top one percent but yeah
but if you I think you should go after
basically the top one percent including
the oligarch so are are you part of top
one percent right now uh I'm probably
part of the top five percent okay but
you're gonna be in the top one percent
very soon maybe maybe not we'll see
there's no question about it you keep
working buddy you'll be there there's no
question capitalism has given you very
good life and you I I think if you keep
continuing you'll be in the top point
one percent so we believe in you Kyle's
what we're trying to say I'm saying I'm
saying the government should tax the
[ __ ] out of me that's what I think
you know uh I make six figures at the
moment um I wouldn't put myself in the
top bracket but yeah I mean so what's
your tax rate like be real what's your
tax rate right now you're in New York
probably I mean New York has kind of
high state taxes and so let's say you
make 200 Grand a year okay so you're
paying a hundred grand in taxes uh
probably closer to like 85 okay
something like that so what are you
comfortable paying you know I think I
think that's a fair rate so what happens
what happens if they took 10 more I
would probably switch it up in terms of
what percentage goes to the federal
government versus what percentage goes
to the state government
um I I'm kind of a believer in a more uh
centralized system I don't like the how
you have so many layers of government
where each one can tax you and they do
different things I'm a big fan of
centralization in the sense that you
know it should be the same rules in
Kentucky as it is in in New York in a
sense but yeah in terms of the amount of
money that I'm taxed sure if that if you
tell me that money is going towards
Healthcare education Pre-K but I'm
saying but you know what you're saying
entertainment
you're saying you don't trust the people
that are getting your money today that's
what you're saying yeah but nobody us
and that's correct so that's right we
all agree on that but if we don't why
give them more because we're trying to
make it so that money goes towards good
things to reallocate it and that's what
I'm fighting for the daily basis but
it's not the point though but you don't
do but I would be a hypocrite if I said
you know what I'm in favor of raising
taxes on all these people but you know
what cut my taxes even though I make
sense that's not the point but but what
we have uh things that we agree with we
don't agree who's getting the money
because they don't have a track record
of doing the right thing with the money
they're already getting from us we
totally agree on that okay so so so to
to do you know like to fix that what we
have to do if it's a lot of work if U.S
was a corporation you have to fire 50 of
the existing people and then bring newer
people in who have ethics to clean it up
that actually have to do the work
because the existing people are not
they're in a swamp type of an
environment that they've been getting
away for a while and no president's
going to be able to fix that the more if
there was anything that we did like if
the last person that said give us this
money and we'll give the money back was
a guy named Abraham Lincoln I think it's
1872 or whatever the year was he says
hey we're going to tax you guys 10 for
the next however many years and then
once we pay off the money we got from
the award the debt then we're going to
stop taxing you guess what happened
after Abraham Lincoln when he did that
they collected the debt they stopped
taxing okay that's how tax was well
collect the money we'll pay off the debt
and will not tax you again until 1913
hey let's FDR let's start taxing
everybody I mean that's a cool way to
collect before FDR that was an FTR no
when Lincoln did it it was uh 1872 of
course it's before FDR but yeah
but when taxes came in it's like hey
let's keep taxing taxing FDL brought
minimum wage 25 cents an hour and then
boom you know he did what he did but the
point is that's what taxes was we know
where it went to today nobody you're
talking about Pentagon five this the
fifth time yeah nobody trusted where the
money is going to right so if if you and
I don't trust an institution that has
shown zero credibility on what to do
with the money we're already being given
them for decades you want us to give
them more money well we're saying the
same thing I'm saying in an ideal system
yeah I should be taxed if you make six
figures or if you make if you're a
millionaire if you're a billionaire yeah
I think their taxes should be Steep and
I think they're still they'll still be
just fine but I think that money should
go towards the thing we've discussed
over and over in this podcast
I understand that but this is what I'm
saying we need to do both things we need
to try to fight for that world and also
I'm not going to sit here and say my tax
rate should be zero my tax rate should
be 10 or something because then I would
be a massive hypocrite everybody would
be right to dunk which is first though
which is I don't think so I think I
think you're 30. January 31st I think
you're trying to do them yes I think
you're trying to do them simultaneously
I don't think you can do that though I
think I think in life you're gonna go
through a lot of philosophical changes
it's what's you're going to be like okay
[ __ ] things change what was this all
about well that's that cool I've been
but what is this you're gonna if you're
the same at 44 as you are 34 there's
problems right it's not going to happen
to it if I'm the same at 50 for Azam
today I wasted it 10 years of my life
I'm gonna have some changes that happen
in my life
for me first starts off with
accountability then when you earn trust
with me then I'll give you more taxes
not the other way around first you have
to prove to me that you're now doing the
right thing with the money then you come
out and say cool you want to go to this
listen man you've proven you do the
right thing here's another five percent
because the last 10 years you've proved
me wrong I didn't trust you but the last
10 years look how responsible you've
been with the money that you've had and
we lowered it for you now you want to
bump a little bit more let's talk about
I understand that I agree with all of it
but nobody should be worried about me is
my point I'm not the person who's
hurting the person who's hurting is the
person who makes 20K a year when they
will work full-time a year when they
work full time so that's my main point
but that's nobody should market value
for the YouTuber who does phenomenally
well for running his mouth for a living
no but but I but I also think I think uh
you're living in a state that has shown
to have zero responsibility what they do
with the money you're not living in a
state that's doing a good job with the
money I lived in California 20 for a
long time 20 some years
I lived in Texas five years and I came
to Florida two years ago I've been here
for two years it's not even two years
yet right it'll be two years yeah your
birthday is going to be two years okay
happy birthday yeah thank you very much
so but but the point is we came here
we were building our media company I
just sold my insurance company six
months ago so I'm sitting there saying
where do I move the media company to I
didn't want to leave it in Dallas
uh we looked at Greenwich okay we're
gonna go to not Connecticut not New York
we're going to go to New York and then
we looked at uh Newport Newport Beach
because I'm from L.A and I like Newport
Beach and then we looked at Texas
Nashville and then last minute Florida
we're looking at Tampa and we looked at
South Florida I didn't go to I didn't go
to New York because it was a [ __ ] show
with the way they handled covid uh taxes
no matter how much taxes you give them
they keep raising it California top of
the chain with taxes you know first time
since 1851 California's lost net net
with amount of people they have their
people leaving that place they don't
trust California Tennessee I lived in
Tennessee for two years I don't want to
go to when I was in the Army I was I
lived in Tennessee for a couple I love
Tennessee but I kind of wanted to have a
little bit of the lifestyle with the
money and then I saw the santis handle
things in the State of Florida I said
yeah there's a place to move down to
because his policies earned the trust of
me moving my family I have a question
for you yeah 2024 Trump versus DeSantis
number one what do you want to happen
number two what do you think will happen
it's a great conversation we've had it
many times I don't think it's pretty I
think it's going to be ugly I think it's
uh this is a part where I'm going to
kind of agree with you on give you
something that you're going to be able
to talk about I think there could be a
civil war on the Republican side I don't
think it will be pretty and I think if a
DeSantis or a trump is wise specifically
more on The Descent side you have to do
negotiations up front before 2024 comes
around meaning
my Camp is sitting down with Trump's cam
right now having conversations
to see if we can do anything here
because if Trump comes out doing what
Trump's going to do it's going to be you
know how Bernie came out calling out
Biden calling out Warren calling out all
that stuff but guess what Bernie did at
the end of the day
he brought them back and he fell in love
there's no way so this is going to
happen who's the favorite right now
between Trump and sentences so you agree
with me oh I've been having this debate
with people in the Republican party you
think the santis is the favorite we got
a disagreement so you think in the
Republicans the Republican primary the
Republicans if we're talking Vegas odds
Vegas put DeSantis at the top then it's
Biden then it's Trump no no I'm saying
in the Republican primary Trump I think
it's the same you think it's absolute I
totally disagree now okay I think
DeSantis is the favorite right now Trump
has I hope you're right Kyle I think a
lot of people might what I said to you
I'm giving you Vegas odds yeah I'm sorry
Trump is two the sentences one wow three
is Biden Trump is two desantises wrong
these are the odds that I trust these
are the polls that I trust
I don't disagree I'm telling you not
raspoosing Quinnipiac Vegas so let me
give you the here's the problem with
Trump electorally in the 2018 election
Republicans got hammered he was the face
of the party in the midterm you mean or
26th 2018 in the midterm yeah in the
2020 election Republicans got hammered
Trump was the top of the ticket Trump
hasn't won since 2016 is what you're
about to say that is exactly right yeah
and the other thing is the candidates
who were most tied to him Doug mastriano
Carey Lake all the ones that were the
most Trump the elections yes they got
hammered and meanwhile you look at a
republican like Kemp in Georgia who is
not an election denier he won and he won
comfortably okay Larry Hogan and uh
Maryland so um
we're talking about honestly I think he
lost his step I think he lost more than
one step Trump did I mean if you see him
over on Truth social now he can't shut
up about the 2020 election it's non-stop
they rigged it they stole it it's
grievance 24 7. he's not talking about
what he wants to do with the country
he's not going after the elites he is
the whiny Elite he said the other day
terminate the constitution on social
media and all this answers has to do is
sit back and chill and let Trump
self-destruct and by the way he's
plotted his way along brilliantly for a
right-wing primary because he did that
thing the other day where it was like a
round table event with a bunch of
vaccine skeptical people the right wing
base loved that there was something else
that he did which I'm blanket on at the
moment but he's been plotting his way
around perfectly where he's not
pro-trump he's not anti-trump he's just
sort of trump agnostic and doing his own
thing and a lot of people are leaving
Trump and going to DeSantis I think he's
the favorite for the Republicans what I
think you're saying is the magic he had
in 2015 2016 is gone it's gone I don't
think anybody would disagree with you
believe me believe it or not there are
people I've had this debate with Crystal
I've had this debate with Saga and I
love both of them but they they've held
strong to this day like no he's still
the Don well that's for 25 of the
country and 40 of the Republican base
that's great that that might win your
primary
that's not going to win your general
election I'm sorry how do you lose to a
walking Corp it's like Joe Biden Joe
Biden is yes you're that toxic of a
candidate correct but but let me go back
let me go back to the point I was trying
to make to you so why did the scientists
all of a sudden get you know he went
from winning by 34 000 votes in 2018
barely winning by 34 000 votes to now
1.5 1.6 million votes what did he do
to become the best governor in all of
America plus minus votes that's a form
of trust including Miami-Dade County
what did he do to become the number one
governor in America well I would say
first and foremost name recognition is
huge he's now the second biggest
Republican name in the country behind
Donald Trump so I think that's a big
thing but how do you get that name
because I honestly I think the media is
not nearly as anti-desantis as they were
anti-trump and he sort of gets part of
it credit though if he's no I will I but
I disagree with him so I'm not I'm not
trying to hide from it or whatever but I
understand that he did things that some
people like I don't like the things that
he did for example he's against raising
the minimum wage even though 60 of
Florida voters said they want to raise
the minimum wage he's against legalizing
marijuana he said it smells putrid so it
probably shouldn't be legalized these
are things I just disagree with now
where I will agree with you there's
politics and there's policy on policy I
don't agree with him at all on politics
I think he's a very good politician and
he's dangerous and he could get elected
well let me let me say say this part
okay do you agree with the policies of
New York how they handle covert no of
course not okay so that I think is a
complicated topic I'm not on so there
are some people on the left who I would
describe as authoritarian where they
said hey shut down the economy you know
force you to wear a mask Force you force
you to get a shot I'm not part of the
authoritarian you're not no no I'm not
no who would you say is in that camp
um Newsome I don't want to oh oh you're
talking about Governors yeah yeah
Newsome was definitely I mean this is a
guy who shot he didn't allow outdoor
eating and then he was eating indoors at
some some restaurant yeah so you're
faring you're you're being reasonable in
those areas no yeah but I would call
myself a covid Centrist in terms of what
policies I would have taken like YouTube
vaccine you probably went through some
of the stuff okay yeah so so for me do
you see yourself living in New York long
term like 20 years ago you've been in
New York well I have family there so I
probably will always be around there
because of family but if it wasn't for
family no look I mean I'm the last Lefty
on the planet that loves Florida but the
reason I love Florida is the [ __ ]
weather I am like the classic case of
the seasonally depressed [ __ ] you
know who needs to get in the sun ASAP
but you know what's crazy about here
like here's what's crazy about here you
know how like in California or New York
if you're on Republican or you're
conservative or you're a capitalist
you may not want to brag about the fact
that you are because it's a different
climate that you have in New York and
California and if you go to Texas
certain parts of Texas if you're on the
left I'm not talking Austin I'm talking
certain areas in Texas if you go you're
like hey I'm a progressive on this you
probably don't want to brag about it you
know what Florida says we don't care if
you're going to come here work make your
money do all this stuff come on down man
if you're going to be doing that part so
so go going back to the question about
policies and what they do with the money
the santis earns the right to say here's
how much money we want to use to do XYZ
are you guys up for it I would entertain
it because of how they've managed things
in Florida so far that's the part what
I'm saying that if we're going back to I
think we need to do more money to be the
same time with Medicare and I want to
know why 45 000 people fine no problem
first earned the right on what you've
done with the other trillions of dollars
we've given you the US government now
you fix that by getting rid of half of
the people that all this wasted money
now you can come back and say guys
because we did such a good job with the
last seven times we raised taxes on you
with your money you gave us we would
like to ask for ask for to follow okay
let's have the conversation like it's
like a budget meeting you're the CMO you
come out and say guys last year I asked
for seven million dollars for my budget
okay yes this year I went up it to 12
million dollars let me see 12 million
dollars Carl what are you gonna do with
it well let me tell you what we do with
the last seven million dollars
last year when you guys gave me a budget
of 7 million here's how much we made 600
000 was used for AdSense for ads on
Facebook that's 600 000 made us 4.2
million dollars the year before we spent
three hundred thousand we only made 600
000 number two we put an event with two
million dollars that two million dollar
event made us 4.8 million dollars last
year we did million dollars at the event
we only made million too so my seven
million dollar budget last year you gave
us I made you 22 million dollars that is
why I'm asking for 12 million bucks and
we say you know what Kyle 12 million you
have 15 million because you've earned
the trust to ask for more money if
American government was a CMO they've
done the opposite we've given them to 7
million and they've come back saying we
need another 10 million yeah I mean I
take your point I think it's a
reasonable point my only disagreement
would be when I look at the government
it's not just a monolith there's so many
different parts of the government that
do different things and are responsible
for different things and so if you tell
me hey we're going to take x amount of
money and we're going to put it directly
into say Medicare or Social Security
um or you know the some program that uh
what's the children's health insurance
program or whatever it was which gives
health insurance to kids if you say
we're going to allocate this exact
amount of money to this then I say oh
definitely I'll sign on the dotted line
right now if you tell me you know it's
going to go towards some subsidy to some
[ __ ] who doesn't deserve to get that
subsidy then it's a totally different
conversation I agree with you completely
so I just I think it's a you know
bureaucracy is complicated uh in general
you know bureaucracy can suck if it's
not efficient right but certain parts of
the government I like better than other
parts of the government were you gonna
say something well I wanted to talk
about a story that you brought up I I
don't want to shift gears though both
want to talk about a story that you
brought up about uh this story it's on
page
um seven you talked about two-thirds of
Americans are now living paycheck to
paycheck right you cited that uh it's a
recent story right how recently's been
pretty bad yeah that's my point yeah and
that's kind of where I was going this
and I'll just kind of say payments
releases latest surveys show that is a
November as of November 63 of American
consumers are living paycheck to
paycheck a three percent increase from
the previous month but roughly the same
time as last year so if you look at the
headlines it's like holy [ __ ] two-thirds
of Americans are living paycheck to
paycheck what's my point with bringing
this up I've been in the finance space
for 15 years I've been I've been a major
advocate of personal finance and
personal responsibility for five plus
years that's how I even got into the
social media World which now turned into
Business and Entrepreneurship and
everything that I do but I've recognized
that two-thirds of Americans have been
living paycheck to paycheck for decades
right yeah okay and where am I going
with this so personal responsibility
personal decisions personal finance and
this is kind of revisiting like the
conversation of like well if you make
better decisions as a dad and do better
than our friend over here of course your
kids should benefit from that it's not
everything is equal so I'll give you a
little anecdotal story I used to go
do a lot of man on the street interviews
so during uh covet in 2021 I would go
down and and interview all the Spring
Breakers and two
two people on the same street shout out
to the people on Ocean Drive down in
South Beach that I interviewed back to
back I interviewed this girl and I was
like what up did you get a stimulus
check she's like oh yeah how much 1800
she goes nope I got 6400 I go 6 400
what's the EP loan right no no she had
dependents you get you get 1800 bucks or
whatever it was 1600 bucks per uh
dependent don't beat me up if it's 16 or
1800 I remember what it was I didn't
qualify but okay I'm like well amazing
you got 6 400 bucks I said how much did
you spend on this trip to South Beach
she goes 6400 I was like holy [ __ ] you
idiot you spent all your money on this
trip to South Beach all right good luck
out there baby then I go interview
another guy I was like huh what's up how
you doing he's like spring break I'm out
here I go how much did you get for
um
for spring break I'm sorry for your
stimulus check he's like uh 3 200 right
I guess he's got a kid or a wife or
whatever it was and I go how much did
you spend on this trip it goes a
thousand bucks I go oh what'd you do
with the rest of it he goes oh I put a
thousand bucks into my Roth IRA I put
another thousand bucks into my savings
then I used another thousand bucks to
actually enjoy my life I go respect to
you bro so these individual decisions
that you make have a major factor in
what you do with life let's take that
deeper let's say you're that exact same
girl that spent 6 400 bucks and that
exact same guy only spent a thousand
bucks since vacation and pumped a lot of
his money into his retirement account to
a savings account God bless you or maybe
he paid off credit cards or maybe he is
saving up for for a down payment as a
loan but okay so now say that that girl
in her free time five hours a day she
knows every show on Netflix she's
watching Game of Thrones and and Game of
Thrones part two and House of dragons
and the other guy is actually watching
pbd podcast two hours a day and twice a
week and he's improving he's getting
smarter and he's reading a book or what
just doing it and the other girl she's
uh playing video games and she's doing
that whereas the other guy is working
out and improving so I'm saying that you
are a byproduct of the decisions that
you make so that girl who's spending all
her money on a stimulus check to go out
and party and watch Netflix and play
video games why should she have the
exact same advantage or the exact same
life or why her should her kids have the
exact same life as that dude who pumped
his money into a Roth IRA into a 401k
that saved his money that worked out why
should their kids have the exact same
starting point when we're all a
byproduct of the decisions that our
parents make okay so the short answer is
you're not going to create a government
bureaucracy to comb through 175 million
people to determine who you think is
worthy and who you think is not worthy
when you do a relief program generally
speaking there's going to be broad
relief in which case yeah some people
might be [ __ ] might be irresponsible
they get the money and others may not be
no doubt the government should give all
the people the money it's all good but
it's on the person to decide what you're
going to do with them well look I don't
think anybody would disagree with that
and yeah you can point at certain
examples of individuals being [ __ ]
with their money but I do think that
misses the bigger picture and here's why
there was a Ubi study that came out of
Stockton California the the mayor over
there somehow got this pilot program
started with universal basic income I
think he gave 500 a month to people and
what they found is that in the
overwhelming majority of cases the money
went towards necessities and so I think
that is more indicative of your average
American the best part of the Cove of
the covid rescue plans in my opinion was
the direct checks to individual people
who were struggling the worst part was
for example the billions of dollars that
went to say the airlines yeah and and
there was there was a you know there
were things attached to that there were
strings attached they said look you
can't fire people if we're going to give
you this money because they were afraid
these airlines are going to take the
money then fire everybody and guess what
they did they gave people early
retirement which was basically firing
them anyway and then here we are today
where they're still understaffed and and
you know we can't if I may I don't want
to interject Colorado I don't want to
get caught up in the fact that these
were government handouts government
bailouts let's just use a different
example we both make ten thousand
dollars as a bonus at the end of the
year we work for the exact same job I
spend my money and max out my 401k and
pay off my credit card bills and and
save some money yeah that's responsible
okay you go spend half of it the club go
to South Beach spend it uh partying at
11 in South Beach big club and you spend
money on strippers and cocaine and have
the time of your life God bless you
invite me next time however
to say that those people should their
kids or the or the byproduct of their
family should have the exact same
situation I have a major problem with
because you have the ability to make the
decisions this isn't government handouts
no but you both got a ten thousand
dollar bonus but out of curiosity do you
think the kids the kid that happens to
have [ __ ] parents so you think there
should be like some sort of punishment
associated with that like what do you
mean [ __ ] apparently let me ask
parents who want better the one who is
irresponsible
better financial decisions no no I'm not
no I I'm saying the person who was
irresponsible the parents who partied on
South Beach or whatever and they had
their kid and that kid is behind the
eight ball obviously because they don't
have the most responsible parents in the
world correct so where's the disconnect
here do you think that kid shouldn't
have health care shouldn't have
education like what do you think they
should I'm saying I'm just saying that
you you want to give free health care
free college and make sure these kids
don't have credit card debt but no no I
don't want eliminate credit card debts
no no saying credit card debt is hot
right well of course but but a lot of
that is because the parenting didn't
teach the kids the right way okay so
like I don't think that we should just
by the way the the student loan thing I
signed whether that's right or wrong I
signed up for my student loans when I
was 18. I took out 25 Grand in student
loans that's on me no so like it's not I
think that's a [ __ ] system and I
think you were Hoodwinked whether or not
you realize it I think in the same way
look I went to public high school I had
I paid zero dollars and zero cents out
of my own pocket it was paid for by the
taxes of the community all I'm saying is
it should apply to college like that too
there are people who start out and
they're in major major debt because
they're like I want to improve my life
and it's like well great now give me a
hundred thousand dollars but at what
point like we all saw what happened with
Sam bakeman freed and everything that he
did and his mother penned uh some
article about I don't I don't believe in
personal responsibility so I I think
kind of like the whole premise of
America is that you're an individual you
can do whatever you want in your life
and say this all the time there's a
major difference between being poor and
broke poor you live in a poor [ __ ]
country and some year in Honduras
whatever you you can't make your money
broke in America you make 50 Grand a
year and somehow you can't get by that
to me doesn't add up because I see the
decision I live in South Beach I see the
decisions people make on the weekends
they spend 300 at a bar tab but they
should have [ __ ] stayed in that night
do you have and that person ends up
paycheck to paycheck complaining about
inflation whereas that is money that
they should probably have just saved
okay but they want to do things that
their friends are doing and they want to
keep up with the Joneses my question for
you is very simple
I think we're having two separate
conversations do you have any systemic
critiques or does it always come back to
the individual the systemic critiques
are fair meaning I think we all agree
that the system is messed up but if you
think that at the end of the day what's
easier to fix the system with a 30
trillion dollar GDP or your life based
on 50 Grand and if your life based on 50
Grand is the easier thing to fix that's
where you should start okay but so like
the problem is the Wailing against the
system and like the the victim mentality
and like oh my God life's so tough straw
man that's true I'm not saying that but
there are a lot of people that say you
have no idea how many conversations I
have with people my [ __ ] boss is an
[ __ ] life sucks they don't pay me
enough it's like you make 50 Grand I see
what you're doing on the weekends buddy
okay you could have stayed in Saturday
night but inside the club it's not a
strong man of working people but every
working person is just some [ __ ] who
[ __ ] off and gets drunk everywhere
that's not what I'm saying people who
are busting their ass and just not able
to pay the bills but they're busting
their ass at their job what are they
doing in their free time my main
disagreement is that I submit to you
people cannot just bootstrap their way
out of this if the system is rigged I
think gets rigged what say you I think
there's a lot of things within the
system that can be improved okay that's
great but if you if you want to go out
but but want to wait for the system to
improve itself and fix your life I've
never said those words go for it buddy
good luck I think I'd rather start with
myself and in year one get out of debt
year two save some money year three
start investing and do something about
it rather than wait four years for
Bernie to try to figure it out first of
all I'd rather take words no I I'm
giving a hypothetical but I would rather
look in the mirror and say I got to do
some things in my life then wait for the
government or Kyle or the system to have
it figured out that's just my opinion
the problem here is
I don't think anybody disagrees with
what you're saying when you talk about
like hey do the best you can work really
hard pick a passion give your all to it
learn expand your horizons if you if you
say those things yeah then I say and I
think any reasonable person would say
100 on board but I think the problem is
when if somebody comes along and has a
separate conversation critiquing the
system because they say it's rigged it's
not fair and then you invoke the
individualistic argument again
in a sense to kind of [ __ ] block the
conversation about the systemic
critiques then I think it becomes a
problem because then the assumption is
the implication is if you just bootstrap
your way out of it you're gonna get out
of it and my my whole point is I don't
think that's possible I think there are
tens of millions of people who are part
of this Working Poor group who did
nothing wrong on their own and the
system just [ __ ] them let me give you
one story uh when I was in high school
the hardest working guy I knew his name
was Kevin okay he rented a shitty little
apartment and he worked two or sometimes
even three jobs was going Non-Stop and
the guy was living at or below the
poverty line I look at that guy and I
say huh what can he do to change this
situation to to be better off and the
answer is honestly not much the problem
is the jobs he's working have [ __ ] pay
and my submit to you yes there should be
rules around that okay this dude should
be able to live a decent life especially
since he's such a hard worker he's such
a good person he should be able to live
a decent life now in terms of the
irresponsible people I agree if you want
to have a conversation about how there's
a bunch of douchebags on South Beach
believe me I know yeah the conversation
that I think we're talking about so
let's use let's be very clear what did
Kevin do for work oh geez he was a a
delivery driver one of his jobs was
delivery driver so he would spend you
know from probably five o'clock at night
until 10 o'clock at night he'd be
delivering pizzas right what was his
name he did uh some Landscaping stuff in
the morning now how did Kevin did he
went to high school with you yes did he
graduate high school uh I don't know if
he ended up graduating hit him in
[ __ ] graduate high school okay so so
Kevin was a screw-up but what if I told
you his parents died and so he had to
pay the bills to look after his siblings
then would you your calculation change
he needs to earn money right now so he
goes to do something to earn money right
now I'm just saying that graduating okay
that's great that's a sub I feel
horribly for Kevin but the reality is
and everyone has a hobster we can go
down the line here well the guy that
graduated high school his parents uh
died but uh he had his parents were
disabled but he still figured it out
like oh this person was black in an
all-white school we can go down the
slippery slope of like oh this person
had it worse than me but we're focusing
on Kevin the problem that I have is yes
there are hard-working people I've gone
down to rallies the fight for 15 rally
in downtown Miami with my one of my best
friends Harris Haitian kid who works his
ass off and I'm seeing the people that
are fighting for 15. they are immigrants
they barely speak English they don't
have anything going on they're working
two jobs I feel for these people but
what what we are in agreement on is that
during that their their time of work
making that those deliveries respect
they're working her ass off my question
is what are you doing with your spare
time we all get 24 hours in a day my
inkling my Inkling is those people who
are still Contin continually living
paycheck to paycheck having two jobs
can't figure it out they're not putting
in the work outside of work we're all
we're gonna fully fundamentally agree on
Kevin the delivery driver it's tough out
there as a delivery driver no doubt but
my question is when Kevin goes home is
he putting on Netflix or is he watching
videos that will improve his life yeah I
think most people would rather put on
Netflix and I think to Pat's credit what
Pat is basically saying is when he was
working at Bally's and his boss is
saying hey went above and beyond yes you
can be like me and make 80 grand a year
just do this he's like dude I want to do
more and I'm going to read books and I'm
going to improve but it's it's outside
of the working hours
that's really what it comes down to for
me yeah those people that are fighting
for 15 I'm wondering what they're doing
outside working hours yeah I mean but
look I mean I think I believe in a in a
good beer a football game or an NBA game
or something like I want people to have
that Leisure Time every single Sunday
though
I mean if you work full-time yes if you
work full-time I think you should be
able to live on that wage yes that's not
how life works though I know but I want
to make it that way but that's why we're
talking that's why we're arguing but
it's not it's not no I I and by the way
first of all I got to tell you I didn't
know if I was going to like you or not
I'm being very honest with you I can't
tell you how much I like you like I
can't wait to have you back on again and
I'm being very sincere with you I'm like
I can't wait to have you back on next
year and and multiple times by the way I
was very excited to come in here knowing
that we don't fully agree yeah I find
that but but there there is you're a
True Believer and that's an easy
conversation to have but to go back and
talk about like I would like to see
everybody be able to take a Sunday off
it's just not reasonable or logical for
the follow-on reasons let me explain why
let me explain I'll go further when
you're done so you know like uh
when people get married and and they we
have this idea of what marriage is like
okay and they get married like oh wow I
didn't know these 73 different things
this idea about having kids let me tell
you 90 of having kids is very difficult
and annoying 90 of having kids so it's
it's to say you know what I would like
every mother new mother that had a baby
to have their Sundays off to do whatever
yeah that's not logical it's not
reasonable yeah I would love every
startup person that's starting a
business to have their Sundays to
themselves not logical not reasonable I
would like every Soldier that's deployed
in Iraq or you know I would like to have
them it's not like the war doesn't
happen on Monday through Saturday it's
not like international law we only fight
Wars Monday through Saturday no hey I
would love for NBA players to have
Sundays off no they're going to play on
Sundays hey I would love these NFL
players have Sundays off to themselves
that's not reasonable hey I would love
these
you know uh people who are going to
church and pastors I want them to have
Sundays up no no that's your worry so
the point the point being anything big
anything worthy anything that you're
gonna be very very proud of is gonna
come with a timeline of you not having a
life okay having a kid you don't have a
life when you're in a military deployed
you don't have a life when you're
running to get your MBA you don't have a
life when you're running to be a
bodybuilder Iranian guy how to show upon
just want to throw Olympia you're not
going to have a life when Ali was
getting ready for a fight 90 days before
a fight you don't have a life so almost
the biggest most incredible rewarding
things that we go through come with a
few years of not having a life so I get
what you're saying where eventually a
person ought to have the right to be
able to dot dot for sure I'm with it but
to say I want everybody to have a day I
I I it's like saying dude your dream is
going to be this demanding do you want
to do that it's going to take two years
if you're not watching any Netflix any
shows are you willing to go through that
I'm not right then don't don't [ __ ]
about it because you can have a choice
can I add to that and then I do want to
respond to that yeah 100 well I I so
much agree with this I was having a
conversation with a girl yesterday she
goes so so what do you do for work I'm
like oh she's like is the value payment
what you do I go no I have a financial
firm that I run and that's where I make
all the majority of my money and I do
the valuetainment thing on the side
which is now turning into a full-on
career at this point right but it didn't
start out that way it started off as a
little side hustle interviewing people
she goes well where do you find the time
to do two careers I go well if you care
that much I I there's a lot of things I
had to eliminate I don't watch football
on Sundays anymore I don't have a TV
anymore I don't watch Netflix anymore I
don't really go out and party all that
much anymore except for you know
occasionally but because what I value so
much of what we're doing here at
valuetainment I'm like [ __ ] it it's
worth another 40 hours a week and doing
this this and and and toggling between
two things because I believe in that so
much but that's because I that's that's
something that I believe in that I want
to do again personal responsibility not
to like put your stuff out there we
talked about this beginning you're
getting married right it's a crystal
congratulations you found love that's
amazing she has three kids you're about
to be a stepfather three kids so
God forbid something happens with one of
the kids God forbid I hope it doesn't
suck it up kid okay all right it's
Sunday or God forbid that you guys end
up kind of living paycheck to paycheck
because you got to put three kids
through private school but it's worth it
is anybody should anybody feel bad for
you that you are don't have more money
than you possibly could because you're
marrying somebody with three kids you
signed up for this is my point and
that's great and that's awesome I wish
you the most amazing life ever but for
me I'm saying I don't know if if if
times get tough It's because you kind of
signed up to having three kids and
that's your decision I respect that
versus the person that's like you know
what I'm not marrying somebody with no
kids I don't want the responsibility I'm
gonna start my own family and start once
but you made those decisions and that's
what I love about America is you get to
pick the life that you want and carve
out what you want from life so let me
respond to all that yeah of course first
of all
um if people want to choose to go
further to do something that's full-time
or Beyond full-time you want you to have
a family you want to choose to be a
soldier you want to choose to be in the
NFL which means you're gonna have to
work on Sunday obviously I'm 100 agree
with all that you're talking to a guy
who when I first started I literally
worked [ __ ] from
10 a.m in the morning to like 2 A.M at
night six days a week every day okay
yeah yes so now congratulate that now
here's the difference though so that was
a that was a choice on my part to try to
go after this I think the disconnect
here is there was a poll that came out
years ago which found I think the number
was 18 of Americans feel quote unquote
engaged at work so in other words only
about 18 of Americans like their job
what do you do in a system where the
majority of the jobs are jobs people
don't really want to do don't like doing
but we need these jobs in order for
society to function and that's where the
conversation we were having before comes
in what should the norm be for the way
we structure our economy should people
have to work for example before unions
came around people would work six days a
week seven days a week and then
eventually we earn the right hey we're
only going to work five days a week and
that became the default that became the
norm so again if you want to choose to
do something by all means go right ahead
I chose to work more than just you know
five days a week but before I said I was
going to go further here I'll go one
step further
I think the norm should be a four day
work week and there's been a number of
pilot studies on this where uh you have
people work four days a week and they're
doing one in the UK they're doing much
and so the productivity in these
companies many of them stayed the same
and some of them the productivity even
went up because it turns out when you
focus on something for maybe a shorter
amount of time but you give your all to
it in that shorter amount of time it's
better than just sort of doing it
non-stop without the leisure time to
sort of recharge your batteries I've
seen a lot of those studies I think a
lot of them do have validity yeah I mean
so the point is like you just pull that
out of your ass I've seen that yeah yeah
so anyway if people want to choose to go
further 100 on favor in board on board
with that uh but I would also say I
think the default should be a four day
work week and I think again I don't
think it's a controversial statement I
think most people agree in fact I think
you guys in your heart of hearts
probably agree with this if you work
full time you should make enough money
to survive that's not too much I'm not
saying everybody a Maserati and two
million dollars if you put in the bare
minimum that's [ __ ] crazy what I'm
saying is if you work full time you
should make enough money and I fully
agree with you and then the four day
work week there's a lot of people that
are doing that a lot of companies are
starting to do that and remote not
remote but there's some people out there
that you're like take your four day
worker you can shove it up your ass I
want to work six seven days a week and I
want to build something no problem and
those people when they end up making a
million dollars or ten million dollars
or 100 million dollars they shouldn't
have to pay the price or pay more than
the person was like look just do let me
do my four days and I'm out wait could
you repeat that I'm saying those people
who choose to sacrifice and work seven
days a week even though the that the
bare minimum is four days those people
shouldn't have to pay more in taxes or
have to feel the brunt of society or
their kids have to bear the
responsibility of that yeah because they
chose to live a more uh they wanted to
have a bigger life yeah well I mean our
core disagreement there is going to be I
believe in a progressive tax system I
don't know do you believe in a flat tax
too is that your idea I think that's a
good idea I think well I think the tax
code at the end of the day is so
freaking complicated anything you can do
to simplify that would be ideal that we
totally agree I would get rid of every
single loophole deduction make that
actual rate on paper make the nominal
rate and the effective rate the exact
same I don't like this thing where it's
like your nominal rate is this but after
we factor in all these 47 so complicated
keep it simple you can play with the
kiss principle yes keep it simple 100
and that's exactly what the tax code is
let's get let's get we're about to wrap
up here to to finish up the podcast this
has been great uh yeah what you just
said right there when you're saying you
know the four day you know throwing that
part in there some people are already
doing this nothing new that's been going
on for quite a few years and even what
social media has allowed people to do is
to make the four hour work day more
realistic I think Tim Ferriss wrote a
book about it called four hours before
hours I never read that did you ever
read it I never read it it's not what I
subscribed to but there are people that
like that and there are people that
enjoy that uh lifestyle for me here's
how I allotted when I sit down and
typically look at what a person let's
just say you do a four hour work for a
four day work week what are you gonna do
with the other three days what does the
average person do with you three days
you know what the average person you
know how much social media consumption
is up or TV consumption or doing nothing
with your life is up for me I want to
know what the best looks like for XYZ
whoever it is for John for Mary for Jack
I want to see that now do they want to
see that or not that's a choice that
they have to make it's not my uh option
to force it down their throat go give
your best to see what your best looks
like I don't give a [ __ ] about that no
problem enjoy your life but if you're
not happy with the money you make just
figure out a way to increase your market
value there's many different ways to
make a living today in America
especially with these technology
companies that we have so many different
ways to make money anyways uh Kyle can I
give one more yeah because I think you
guys will actually we'll end on a point
of I think giant agreement which is so
you know my job I talk about politics
economics news give my opinion on it and
everything but I do have a personal life
philosophy that I abide by in my own
life and I would recommend if you know
if people like it they give it a shot
too I call it passionism which is very
similar to what you just described which
is
I think you get the most happiness and
meaning and joy out of life if you have
a thing that you like and you give your
all to it and you leave it all out there
on the field and uh whatever that thing
is I don't care what it is if you want
to build [ __ ] you know toy sailboats
by all means go ahead you want to give
your all to a sport by all means go
ahead if it's a particular profession
that you enjoy by all means go ahead but
find something that makes you happy
almost like innately where you get
excited when you hear about it for
whatever reason you did when you were a
kid or you came to like when you were
older give your all to it leave
everything on the field and then you'll
be surprised what can happen and where
that could take you I mean there's no
promises it's one of the reasons why I
like the idea of a four-day work week
because some people they just don't make
money off of the thing that they love
that's the unfortunate reality of the
world that we live in so for those
people I want to give them enough time
to expand their Leisure enjoy their time
do something they love even if it's not
their main economic pursuit in life
um but just give it your all and see
where it takes you and I guarantee you
at the end of the day you'll be happier
because
with passionism it's more about the
process than it is the end goal it's not
about like okay if I do X Y and Z I'll
get the million dollars or I'll get the
women I'll get what no no the whole
point of it is the beauty is in the
process of it if you love something you
give your all to it you don't stop
um you'll be a much happier person just
by going down that path fully agree I I
get what you're saying for me I I
subscribe to the 420 Rule and I don't
mean by smoking weed every day at 420
although that sounds pretty cool for
many first 20 years don't screw it up
man just learn a little bit about life
second 20 years make your money and
really go make your money third 20 years
use that money to invest into your
passions and in the last 20 years go
figure out a way to go contribute back
to society whether it's going to be
charity politics service whatever it is
education but make your money sometimes
when you I chase my passion part-time I
chased retire my dad at a 99 Cent Store
full time I didn't grow up saying I'm
going to go sell life insurance for the
rest of my life I did that because I saw
that as a vehicle to allow my dad to no
longer have to work because he worked at
a 99 cent store for a long time site you
know pursue my passion non-stop of
course but sometimes the concept with
passion alone
it distracts you from doing things that
we only have to do because we like it
listen a lot of things I've done in my
life I did not like that has allowed me
to do the things I'm doing now that I
love and like a lot but there's gonna be
a face that you're going to go through
that you're not going with kids we're
gonna have I love having a conversation
I'm having with my 10 year old son I
love the conversations today I love the
conversation with my nine-year-old son
it's an incredible conversation today
there's a lot of times that I didn't
enjoy what I was doing as a father it
was a very annoying thing that I was
going through anyways Kyle this has been
a blast Adam I enjoyed you guys also
having a banter together it was purely
class out of everybody that was here I
had a great time we can't wait to have
you back on again appreciate your
philosophy appreciate you coming out
here and giving your ideas to it guys if
you enjoyed it uh give it a sub to the
channel also Rob can we put a link to
his channel as well both in the chat and
in the description for them to go find
his comment he's got a lot of different
things opinions on a lot of different
things he talks about if you didn't
catch it he's also got a sensitive humor
he's a funny witty sarcastic guy which
is my kind of a humor that I like but
Kyle appreciate you for coming out guys
it was this was a blast yes I think
we're doing podcasts again tomorrow no
we're doing tomorrow home team zener is
going to be here and Sam Sorbo I think
yes no you give me a weird look uh well
uh that's just his face okay we'll
figure it out we'll figure out what's
gonna happen anyway we're doing a
podcast tomorrow we got like 60 topics
to go through yeah tomorrow on it take
care everybody bye bye bye bye